Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
I am super excited to try out today's game, The Simpsons Hit and Run.
Um, I don't know why it took me a year to realize that I'm, like, indie.
Which means I can play anything I want, like, even if these games are technically, like, you know, not really available anymore.
And it really did take me, like, a year to finally realize that.
Like, because, like, every week, I'm like, oh, what do I play?
What do I- what do I fucking play?
And I was like, wait, I've always wanted to play The Simpsons Hit and Run because, um, I actually never grew up with this game.
I've seen a lot of people talk about it.
I see a lot of people play this game, even to this day.
Like, it has a really big speedrun community, apparently, um, which is how I was able to get this game running.
Um, because the speedrun community for this game is, like, um, really big for The Simpsons Hit and Run.
And there's, like, an entire website just dedicated to, like, um, giving you ac- like, giving access to it.
And then there's, like, big modding community for this game as well, which is how, like, you know, I YouTubed it, I Googled it in regards to how I set this up and everything.
So, um, so yeah, this is the PC version of The Simpsons Hit and Run.
Uh, for some reason, I just never, ever had a chance to play this game before.
Um, when it first came out, uh, when it first came out, um, my dad would never buy me this game for some reason.
Um, because I know it was out on the PlayStation, but I still never had a chance to actually play it.
Because back then, I was very limited to what I can and can't play, uh, growing up because the PlayStation, uh, the PlayStation 2 was my dad's console.
So, he only lets me buy, like, you know, if it's, like, a special occasion, I get to buy a game.
And I usually play my dad's hand-me-downs growing up.
So, like, you know, he would be playing, like, Call of Duty, Battlefield, Medal of Honor, stuff like that.
And then I would have, like, Kingdom Hearts.
I got to play Kingdom Hearts.
Um, that's, like, my, like, he only buy me games when, if he could play it as well.
So, like, you know, if he's not on it, I get to play on the game as well.
So, the rare moments when I did have, like, games I could play myself was Kingdom Hearts, um, Piglet's Big Game, apparently.
I don't know why.
I don't, I don't know why Piglet's Big Game was one of them.
Um, and, like, I don't remember.
I literally, oh, and Spyro.
It was, like, Spyro and Crash Bandicoot.
It was Spyro, Crash Bandicoot, uh, Piglet's Big Game, and Kingdom Hearts.
Like, those are the games that I remember I used to, I had, like, I was actually able to play, um, that was, like, that was not just, like, for my dad.
Um, I've actually been thinking about playing Kingdom Hearts after Dynasty Warriors, but then, like, I was, like, oh, it's an incredibly long game.
It is very long.
I mean, Kingdom Hearts 1 is shorter than Kingdom Hearts 2, but it is an incredibly long game.
So I might not start with that one first off, but I need something more chill than Dynasty Warriors.
For those who didn't watch last stream, oh, sorry, I just, I just swallowed a hiccup.
Oh my god, that was not good.
That did not feel good.
Um, for those who did not watch yesterday's stream, um, Dynasty Warriors is, the Dynasty Warrior origin game is not your regular Dynasty Warriors game, because for some reason, they tricked me and added Souls-like into the boss fights.
And so I was stuck for one hour on loop-loop, fucking fighting it as if I was in Dark Souls.
I felt like I was playing a fucking Souls game.
Um, so I need, I need something much more chill than, I need something a lot more chill.
I was also thinking about maybe, I wanted to try Sly Cooper.
I've never played Sly Cooper before, and I know there's a way, there's like a way to play the first, like the way play the first trilogy of the game.
And I've always been interested in the Sly Cooper series, but um, and I was thinking about maybe trying that out after Dynasty Warriors, like another, like a different series for it.
Um, and it's much more chill.
It's definitely much more chill than, than Kingdom Hearts or Elder Ring.
Um, if it wasn't, okay, if it wasn't for that Lu Bu fight, we would have went straight to Elder Ring, but like, I need a break.
I, I, I need a break from like Souls-like games.
I, I cannot spend hours on a boss right now.
I just want to finish like a new series.
I, Lu Bu killed, Lu Bu pursued me and killed Elder Ring.
He killed, he kills the ones you love.
Um, so yeah, that's gonna be like the future of the schedule.
So, uh, most likely it will be a Sly Cooper right after Dynasty Warriors.
I will be completing Dynasty Warriors Shu Kingdom, um, on YouTube.
And then Wei and Wu will be moved to Twitch because like, um, just like how I said in the Dynasty Warriors streams, my manager was like, this would be the Yakuza of your chat, of your channel.
Cause it's like, you need to start a new series.
You cannot keep playing Dynasty Warriors.
It's like, at least Yakuza has like different things to do.
All you're doing is, at least it has like a variety of mini games in Yakuza.
Like,
you cannot be stuck romancing Chinese generals and beating people up till the end of 2025.
And so, so, um, the moment I finished, finished the Shu Kingdom, he's, it's being moved to Twitch.
Uh, yeah, there's no karaoke in Dynasty Warriors.
Um, hey guys, uh, like I said, I didn't grow up with The Simpsons Hit and Run, but I've always seen, I've always seen like those like demos, you know, like those little mini demo play, uh, like PlayStations that they put up, um, in like GameStop slash EB Games for,
is EB Games a Canadian?
I don't know.
I always mix up.
EB Games is the Canadian, right?
EB Games.
Yeah.
So it's either, oh wait, no, GameStop is the Canadian.
Sorry.
EB Games is the American version.
I don't remember.
Or was it, or did GameStop buy EB Games?
I, oh yeah, sorry, EB Games.
I forgot that GameStop bought EB Games.
So they're now all sort of called, they're sort of called GameStop now.
Um, yeah.
So I forgot it would, it has not been called EB Games in a very long time.
Um, but yeah, uh, I, no, no GameStop literally bought out the entire branch of EB Games in Canada.
So like, we don't have that anymore.
Uh, anyway, uh, I would like watch the other kids play on their little, like, you know, those little demo state, demo stations that they have.
And I've always wanted to try it out, but like I said, it was just, you know, wrong time for me where my dad didn't buy it.
So I didn't get a chance to try the game out.
So I heard it's like, it's like GTA, but for kids, right?
Like, that's what I heard what this game is basically about.
Um, the only other Simpsons games I've ever played was the arcade version, the beat-em-up arcade version.
Um, uh, the classic one.
And then the, what was it?
And then the Simpsons game.
I played the Simpsons game where you go to heaven and then like, where you go to heaven to kill God or something.
Um, I played that one and the classic arcade game, but this is the one, this is the game I didn't play.
I didn't even play the crazy taxi one because it was like before my time.
Um, before I like could touch a console.
Um, so yeah, let's check it out.
All right.
Let me launch this game.
Let me know the sound is okay too.
When it pops up because it plays the theme song.
I also got it running with my controller and everything.
I'm prepared guys.
See, look at that.
I can prepare.
All right.
And then it's this one.
I think it's this.
Look at that guys.
Look at that.
See that.
Oh, and it works on widescreen too, which is great.
I'm going in blind.
Look at that.
Oh, I know how to set up streams before stream.
Do I do it consistently?
Maybe not.
But sometimes, sometimes productive doki is there.
Oh, there's Bart.
I heard the newest season, the last two seasons of Simpsons actually really, really good now.
I brought it down a little bit.
Is it better?
Hello.
Goodbye bees.
How big are these bees?
Yeah, I heard, I heard they got new writers and everything.
Okay, nice.
Oh, age really.
I didn't age that.
The graphics actually live up a little bit.
Let me put that ahead.
I've actually been watching...
I've been watching the last season so far and I honestly enjoy it.
It's actually really weird because like time, like you know, there's no set established time in the Simpsons universe.
So like, like, you know, they're always, they're always going to be the same age.
So the whole premise is that they never, they never age up.
And now like, it's really weird because I'm because like, Abraham Simpson is now like used to be like, part of the World War, right?
Like his whole premise was that he was part of World War Two.
But now he's like, yeah, the war I was in, which is now the Vietnam War.
Yeah, so it's like, it's so weird.
And then they're like, yeah, when Marge was pregnant with Bart, that was like 10 years ago.
So like, technically they were parents in 2010.
And so it's all it's, it's so weird.
Like, yeah, now it's like, it's like a floating timeline.
So they have been like continuously retconned to fit like, what 10 years ago was.
So technically, Marge was pregnant with Bart 10 years ago in 2010.
So it's so weird.
All right, let's bring down the music.
Okay.
Yeah, Homer is technically a millennial now.
Oh, all right.
Sound.
Music.
All right, let me know if it's better.
All right, is it better now, guys?
Does it sound better, sound guy?
Bum, bum, bum, ba-dum, bum, bum, ba-dum.
Millennial Homer, yeah, he's literally a millennial now.
Millennial with three kids and a house and working at a nuclear power plant.
Like, he's living the dream.
He's actually, he's just living the fucking dream right now.
All right, new game.
Oh, what's this?
Whoa, that we know.
Oh, it's Buzz Cola.
Plus, it has a special ingredient too hot for the FDA.
It'll give you the get up and go.
You need to do all the pathetic stuff you have to do.
Try new improved Buzz Cola.
Hey guys, did you hear that, that we have just restocked the Hyatt PC case, guys?
You can get right now at your local Hyatt store.
Use WASD and space bar to jump.
Okay, so that is...
Oops, sorry.
Sorry, Marge.
Get over there, woman.
That's right.
Use coins to purchase cars and clothes.
Okay.
All right, how do I talk to you, Marge?
Marge?
Oh, wait, I can get arrested?
Nah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I'm sorry, Marge.
How do I go inside?
Oh, how do I go inside?
Okay, there, there, there.
All right, can arrest me if I'm at home.
Oh, find all gags?
I didn't know I could get arrested for kicking her.
How was I supposed to know?
We're family.
Okay, hello, Marge.
Nothing happened.
Okay, I need to know what button is what.
I let her kick me.
Okay, the cola caper.
Go to the quickie mart and purchase some ice cream and cola.
Okay, I got that.
Where's my car?
Dude, where's my car?
Left click to get inside the car.
What's left click?
Press W to accelerate, A, D to steer, and S to brake.
Right click to...
Okay, guys, what are any of those on my controller?
Okay, that's get out of the car.
Honk.
Wait, oh, shit.
Oh, I reset my car.
Guys, I'm trying to figure out...
I'm trying to figure out how to drive.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
I can honk.
I can do everything but drive.
Oh, oh, it's start button.
Okay, I figured it out.
It's the start button.
Brake object.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
So, I can just brake things.
All right, nice.
All right, I know how to drive.
It's okay.
As long as it doesn't hit blue, I should be fine.
As long as it doesn't hit blue, it should be fine.
So, I can run over as many people as I want.
See, look at that.
All right, nice.
I don't know why driving is the start button, but like, I'll take it.
Wait, look, there's a wrench.
Jackson, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's always tradition when you get the game for the first time to kick Marge.
I don't know why everyone does that.
Wait, what does the wrench just do?
I didn't pay attention.
Okay, why the fuck is start button drive?
What does the wrench do?
Kick, kick, kick.
Yay, free money!
If it touches the floor, it's free.
Oh, it repairs my car.
Wait, my car can't get damaged?
Hello, Appu.
Oh, it's Sam!
Did that free him?
Oh, hey, Christy.
What are you looking at?
Hello.
Can I like... Is there anything I can take here?
Ever since the accident.
The multiple accidents.
Yay!
I finished the first mission!
It's not nudie master, I'll clothe.
It's like the most...
The most like... Also like if you read those magazines in the public area, I'm pretty sure you get arrested.
He's most likely just reading a cosmopolitan.
Oh, hey, clothes.
100 coins to purchase casual.
Is casual just me naked?
That's my casual wear.
The chosen one.
No, I'm broke right now.
I don't have money.
All right.
Let's get out of here.
Did I just go home?
Oh, I have to go home.
Hello, where's my car?
Oh, I left my car here.
All right, let's go.
It's time to go home.
Fuck, okay.
As long as it doesn't go to blue, I can run over as many people as I want.
It's like the three strikes rule.
Hurry up.
Oh, yeah, see?
I still have time.
And then shortcut.
All right, just today though.
Just only today.
That's a bad day.
Hello, Marge.
Oh, no!
Don't worry, I got you, mom.
I have to go to work?
Oh my God, same, Homer.
I'm like, I have to go to work?
Try the school, where's my car?
Oh, wait, there's my car.
I need to reset my car.
All right.
Whoops, sorry.
All right, here we go.
Wait, shortcut!
If I go this way, it'd be faster, because it's a shortcut.
Get out of here, Skinner!
All right.
Let's see, where do I go?
Where's the school?
Why is the school so far away?
All right, nice.
See, Skinner follows traffic rules.
And those are just suggestions.
Oh, fuck.
All right, wait, wait.
Okay, never mind.
I figured it out.
Don't worry, I'm here.
I'm here now, I made it.
Don't worry, Lisa!
Daddy's got your project!
I did it.
Lisa, where are you?
I got your school project.
Everything is food, technically.
If it goes in my mouth, it's food.
Yay!
Kongo, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Guys, we're scared of Shredder.
Showing this game to the show creator, because maybe he won't like that you can kick everyone.
The first thing he did was kick Marge all the way.
Wait, how come he doesn't get arrested?
How does he not... Wait, can I kick Lisa?
Wait, I can kick everyone?
Okay, Lisa, get over here.
Hey, Ralph.
Oh, I can't kick him.
That was a lie.
That's a lie.
I can't believe you lied to me.
I can't kick everyone.
I can only kick...
Wait, I can only kick my wife?
Okay, that's a little bit fucked up.
All right, let's go home now, I guess.
Back to my wife.
Don't worry, see?
Three second rule.
As long as it doesn't go blue, everything is fine.
Your only suggestions.
All right, where is home?
Is there a shortcut for home?
I think he's hungry, but it's like way too early for food.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that was... I can run over one more person.
That's okay.
That lets me have one more person.
All right, as long as I don't...
As long as I follow the traffic suggestions, I won't get arrested.
Oh, I can run over another person.
All right, nice.
All right, I choose you.
And maybe you.
All right, as long as I don't break any other traffic suggestions, I'm fine.
Oh, I get one more.
I get one more.
Nice, okay.
Oh, he's coming over.
He's coming over.
He's like, you didn't listen to... Okay.
Okay, dad, I'll feed you.
I'm back.
He was not happy.
He was like, did you not hear me bark?
How dare you make me walk all the way over to be fed.
Yeah, everyone knows I'm gonna go to heaven.
You should respect me.
I'm God's chosen child.
All right, where's Flanders?
Hi diddly ho, neighborino.
What do you want, Ned?
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not going to read that.
Who could have done such a thing?
Yeah, it can't be me.
Collect all six of Ned's lost items before time runs out.
Wait, I have to do that?
Can I just like never return them?
He'll forgive me.
A good Christian man will always forgive thy neighbor.
Let me just steal his money real quick.
He'll forgive me.
To destroy WASP cameras, jump into the air with a space bar and then right click.
Wait, there we go.
Oh, money.
Okay, oh nice.
I can't believe there's all these lost items in Ned's backyard.
Wow.
Don't worry, I'll keep good.
I'll keep good look for them.
Oh, what's in here, Ned?
I'll make sure to look after them.
Is that Ralph?
Wait, not Ralph.
Todd?
Yeah, he doesn't need it anyway.
He doesn't drink.
He's a good Christian man.
Okay, I need to go find his items and get in the car.
What's he doing with a bomb shelter?
Does he not trust- does he not trust me?
Find Ned's tuxedos.
Fuck, okay.
Where did I put it?
Where did I put his tuxedo?
All right, nice.
Why is it over here?
Okay, I need to find his lawnmower.
Where is it?
Where the fuck did I put his lawnmower?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, nice.
I like how they're all conveniently like in front of me.
And then there is- oh, hey, Barney.
Oh, shit.
Hey, Barney, are you part of Ned's lost items?
Please don't do- What do you want?
You remember that cooler I gave you for your birthday?
Well, Flanders wants it back.
Now what will I use for a toilet?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Was apparently- guys, guys, I can't- I can't go to my options, so I can't turn down the music.
Oh, no.
All right, where do I go?
I have to go...
Please move!
I have the right of law!
Move!
This is my path!
I'm doing a u-turn!
All right, what's wrong with your cont- I have no idea.
I don't think this game works with an Xbox controller very well.
His wife's dead anyway.
He doesn't need a picture to remind him of his trouble.
All right, I'm doing him a favor, making him forget that he has a wife.
Yeah.
He can, like, not breathe for a second longer.
Yay!
That's just a song, not real life.
All right, let's see.
Oh, I have to go here.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh, nice!
Yay!
All right, time to get back to Ned.
You won't know- he'll call- He might give me a reward money for finding his lost items that I didn't borrow.
All right.
Oh, come on, guys.
Let me have some fun.
Get in front of my car.
It's okay.
I get, like... I get, like, six people I can run over per day before the cops get me.
All right, hello, Ned.
I got your stuff!
Hello.
I found it.
Do I get a reward?
You're missing stuff.
No, about the reward.
Thanks, neighbor Rooney.
Here's your reward.
A prayer from the Lord's number one fan.
What?
Father in heaven, bless this noble oaf.
Stupid Flanders getting happiness from religion.
How dare he be happy with religion?
I can't believe it.
Why can't I be happy?
Why do I have to be depressed?
Joel, thank you for the 10 gifted shits.
Thank you.
You are forgiven.
Why can't he be miserable like the rest of us?
I, um... Hello, my wife.
Oh, shit.
I forgot about my work.
Wait, Gabe does an autosave?
Wait, I don't know how to get to my main menu.
There's no... There's no option buttons.
What do you mean?
There's no option buttons, guys.
I can't get to my menu.
Wait, oh, I just pressed escape.
Guys, I figured it out.
I have to use my keyboard.
Never mind.
All right, sound.
I'll turn down the music a little bit.
And then...
Bring it up a little bit more.
Okay.
Oh, let me know if it's better, guys.
Let me know if this sounds better.
Sound guy.
All right, I just have to...
Wait, how do I save?
Oh, there it is.
Save game.
Did it work?
All right, nice.
Okay, save successful.
Level progress.
All right, let's go.
Dude, where's my car?
I keep forgetting where I park it.
Oh, I parked it at Ned's place.
Nice.
I love my free... free parking at my neighbor's house.
Stupid fucking planners.
How can you be happy?
Why can't you be miserable like the rest of us?
All right, let's see.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Free wrench.
Oh, yeah.
Here we go.
Hey, Lenny.
Oh, shit.
That's okay.
I still have... I still have four more forgivens.
Yeah.
All my homies hate planners.
Borrow the Plow King to complete this mission.
You will need the Plow King.
Purchase it at the gasoline station for 150 coins.
Use phone booths to access... I need to pay Barney?
I'm his best friend!
The amount of...
The amount of duff beer I bought him should be enough to fucking... I owe you a fucking Plow King.
Barney, if you're my friend, you would give it to me for free.
Just don't shoot me with that dark gun.
Whatever.
He said take it.
Why do I have to buy it?
Can't believe it.
He's not a homie.
Destroy Smitter's car before he gets to the... Yay!
Vandalism!
I love vandalism.
Thanks for the car, bro.
That's for making me pay for it.
Where's the phone booth?
Did I destroy it?
Oh, no.
There it is.
All right.
Where's his car?
It's okay.
He won't know it's me because, like, technically it's Barney's car.
All right.
It's nice that, like, everything is conveniently near me.
This is a lovely neighborhood for a millennial.
All right, only if I get caught.
Okay, I'll go through the shortcut.
Yay!
Shortcut!
I am excellente!
Free money!
All right, where is he?
When this is over, I'm hitting the store.
Oh, there he is.
Where's Smitter's car?
Take that!
Where is it?
Wait, where is it?
Where's his car?
Oh, is he driving away?
Wait, he can do that?
Get over here.
I don't want to go to work.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
The worst thing is I'm not imagining these guys.
They'll understand.
It's fine.
When are you gonna catch me?
Oh, shit!
Oh, shit.
Guys, I think I got caught.
I think I got caught.
Oh my god, get back here.
Yeah.
Wait, where is he?
I don't know how to go backwards, guys.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god, it's just because I let them catch me.
I literally got out of my car, guys.
I let them catch me.
It's okay, shortcut.
I got him now.
You can't get away.
Oh, shit.
God damn it.
These controls are so dumb.
Please, I'm trying to figure out how to go backwards.
Oh my god, I need to rebuy my controls.
Smitters, give me a sec.
Please, get over here.
I need to rebuy my controls.
Smitters, please.
Time out.
All right, nice.
There we go.
I have to reset my car every time.
I don't know how to go backwards.
Okay, he's almost there.
It's all right.
I'm pretty sure Mr. Burns gave you insurance, right?
There's no way.
Our ever-loving boss, who loves his workers, definitely got you insurance.
All right, where are you?
Yeah, exactly, Smitters.
You should have learned to drive better.
I get to go to work now.
Yippee.
Okay, I should rebuy my controls.
I'm just like, I can't.
All right, controller.
Vehicle control.
Um, reverse.
What the fuck is J button six?
Oh, that's two.
Okay, I don't need to boot my horn, I guess.
Action, get out.
Okay, how do I start?
Okay.
Press A to start.
That should be my reverse.
Um...
It's the six button, of course.
Um, I'll put this for...
brake, and then this would be my e-brake.
Uh, the rest is okay.
All right.
Nice.
Now, guys, I can finally reverse.
I did it.
I finally learned how to reverse my car.
I'll never know what J button six is.
Yippee.
There is no road.
Technically, every pathway is a road, if you think about it.
It's not my fault.
There's not even a sidewalk.
That's your fault for standing there.
That's the bike lane.
So we're both breaking rules.
All right.
Yippee.
Off to work I go.
I love my job.
Yay!
Oops.
Oh, wait.
I'm supposed to get out.
Oops.
Give me a sec.
Let me head to my job real quick.
Let me clock in.
Do my nine to five.
Hello.
The safety inspector is here.
Oh, no.
Anime girls could be watching me right now.
Destroy all the power couplings before the time runs out.
Wait, what are they?
Is it this?
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Get out of here.
Exactly.
I don't want to be monitored.
Thingy goes down.
Can't monitor me if they're all... if they're all broken.
Accidentally.
Oh my god.
They're so faulty.
They just break like that.
Mr. Bird should invest in something...
Something more concrete.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Wait, what?
Where do I go from here?
Oh.
Where do I... Oh, nice.
No.
Why is it so fast?
All right, nice.
Fuck!
Okay, I got this.
I got it this time.
Okay, I figured it out.
I jump across it.
All right, up I go.
All right, across I go.
Goodbye.
All I'm saying is that...
It... I can't believe they just like accidentally fell down like that from a high...
From a high place.
Oh my god.
Okay, eight.
Last one.
Nine.
Yay!
I did it!
I did my job!
Emily, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Save.
And I get money!
Yippee!
All right, did my job.
Did what Mr. Bird is paying me to do.
Finally, I can get some sleep.
Mindless drones, return to your ugly families.
I'm so talented and good looking.
Yeah, I get to... I get paid to destroy stuff.
Yay!
I love my job.
Where's the phone booth?
All right, I need to get my car.
Uh...
All right.
Gotta go home.
Happy wife is a happy life.
How do I go backwards?
Okay, just backing up.
Backing up.
Oh, I can just drive like this.
Okay, never mind.
It was a lot harder than I thought.
I didn't kill anybody.
They're okay.
If they're dead, why is there like three of them?
If I kill one out of a... out of triplets, then technically... technically they have three lives.
Or two lives after that.
All right.
Nice.
All right, time to go home.
Shortcut!
Ow.
Oh my god, do I just have duff beards?
Look at that.
It's like an extra life if you have triplets.
Is that another car?
Gil, do you have a car for me?
What car do you have?
I know you're always broke.
The wolf is at old Gil's door.
Oh my god, it's a duff truck?
I can't afford it.
I'm broke.
Don't worry.
I'll just use Bart's college fund.
He's not gonna need it.
He'll never turn 11.
He'll be 10 forever.
What is he gonna do?
I'll just use the shortcut with the cemetery.
Okay, never mind.
Apparently the door to the cemetery is like really really strong.
All right, we need to find a wrench.
My car does not look so good and I don't have insurance right now.
I don't think and I don't think I'll ever get insurance.
Not just right now, but maybe ever.
All right, nice.
All right, I'm back home, Mike.
Back to my loving wife and family.
Where are they?
Hello?
I worked so hard to...
So I can get like, you know, a nice home-cooked meal.
Not the women!
Yeah, where are they?
Oh, there's one over there now.
Yeah.
Oh my god, Marge, do you think the government sent out those pigeons to spy on us?
Imagine that's their like in bed talk.
I was like, oh, you want me to get a pigeon right now and let the government watch?
Yeah, Marge.
Did you hear that the earth might be flat?
Don't kink shame.
And that they faked the moon landing.
Oh, they just released the documents to JFK's assassination, Marge.
God damn it, I keep getting out of the car.
Tell us more about the pyramids, homie.
Okay, oh, isn't that sexy?
You want to read the documents right now in bed?
All right.
I can almost see the car.
I can almost see where it is.
It's okay.
What's gonna happen?
The car's gonna fucking explode.
All right, I'm right here.
I'm literally right next to you.
Where is he taking me?
Am I supposed to destroy the car or like, oh no, I just have to be next to him.
Okay, the green bar is like it being further away from me.
Where is he going?
Where are you going, sir?
That's my job.
I literally just left work to avoid work.
Okay.
Look at that.
Oh, when I run over people, I don't get hurt.
I don't get like the police meter.
So I can kill as many people as I want here.
Boop.
Where am I?
Oh my god, I'm at the chosen one.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck, no, my car!
No!
My car!
Wait, give me a sec!
Let me call my next car!
No!
Oh, Mr. Burns is behind all this.
Wait, I did it.
Spying is so like him.
That wrinkled old monkey skeleton.
Wait, did I finish?
Wait, did I?
Yeah, I did it!
Yay!
Wait, is that my car?
Is it still drivable?
Hey, it's still drivable.
Nice.
It still works.
All right, let me drive home.
Hahaha!
Reminded me to never get in the car with Doki.
No, no, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry, I can fix my car right here.
See guys, it works!
My car is still working!
Don't worry, I'm almost at the wrench!
Come on, little guy!
Hahaha!
Just get over!
Okay, I can't go upstairs.
Now I know.
Don't worry, I'll find another wrench.
It's okay, even though my car is barely a car.
I can still cause mayhem.
Get over here, people!
I need to get my quota in.
Five people per day.
That's right!
Even with this, I can still run over people.
Guys, I'll get the wasp the moment I find a wrench, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm slowly coming over.
You can't run away from me!
You can't run away!
It's like bullying!
Hahaha!
All right, don't worry guys.
I'll get- listen to that baby purr!
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Wait, they're all just like powerp- like, sorry, power plant workers.
All right, I can fix this.
Yeah, don't worry.
My car will be fixed here.
All right.
Don't worry, I can fix my car.
There you go.
See?
Good as new.
Look at that.
I told you guys.
Nothing to worry about.
Where are all the power plant workers?
All right, now there's real people.
Never punished.
Hey, where's Marge?
Marge, why are you at the grocery store?
Why are you at the nicer grocery store?
We're supposed to stop at the quickie mart.
We can't afford this.
Everybody we've got to follow him.
Not now, Homer.
A new violent video game has hit the streets and we need to get rid of it before it warps any children.
Oh, no, not violent video games.
And therefore should be destroyed.
I guess.
Oh my god.
Okay, hit the delivery truck and collect our bonestorm games before time runs out.
All right, where is it?
Don't worry, Marge.
I'll do what you want me to do for you.
Happy wife happy.
Oh my god.
Who let this grandpa drive?
All right.
Nice.
If a grandpa's driving it, that means like we can blame it on him.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
If I like... oh shit.
Oh shit.
Nice.
All right.
If I let him stay there.
No, I trapped him in the corner.
Stay in the corner.
Grandpa, stay in the corner.
Wait, I think I dropped... wait, didn't I drop a couple of items already?
Oh, they despawned.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out how you return.
Get back here, Gramps.
I gotta stop violence with violence.
Oh, no.
All right.
It's okay.
I got this.
It's all right.
I still have a bar.
All right, is he dropping it?
Where is it?
Oh, nice.
I dropped... he dropped it.
Oh my god.
Who would have thought driving is so hard?
Guys, I have a driver's license.
Boom.
All right, come on.
No, no, no, no.
All right, three.
Oh, sorry, Dad.
It's all right.
All right, nice.
You should have dropped another one.
Jesus Christ.
I need to do this nine more times.
Wait, not nine.
Six more times.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Okay.
Come on.
Drop it.
Drop the box.
Wait, is that two?
Oh, shit.
God damn it.
Okay, that's two.
Nice.
All right, four more.
I can do this in a minute.
Get over here.
Give me my free game.
Think of the children.
Children don't need this.
I need it.
Oh, shit.
Nice, I got it.
One more.
Get over here.
I didn't pre-order the game, so I need to do this.
Oh no, 25.
25 seconds.
Get over here.
I need one more.
I need one more on eBay.
Nice, I did it.
My Switch pre-ordered.
No.
All right, now I'm gonna- This is- This is how I scalp, guys.
Yippee!
Okay, thank you for the five gift-a-ships.
Thank you.
All right, now to put them on eBay.
I have to go back to work?
Why?
I have to go back to work.
I just did my jo- I have to go back to work every day to get paid?
That's a thing?
It's not one- I ask myself every day.
What do you mean I have to go back?
I just- I was there yesterday.
Too real.
All right, time to go back to work, I guess.
What's the point?
They're never gonna go to college anyway.
They're gonna be 10 forever.
Also, if you work at a power plant, do you get like discounts?
You know, like employee discount for energy?
I feel like that should be a thing.
I should get like employee discount.
Didn't Lisa go to college?
No.
Technically, it's like a vision.
She didn't actually- She gets a vision that she's going to college, but she's not actually gonna go to college.
Yeah, it's in my electricity bill.
I'm literally providing energy, so I should get employees discount.
How come like other employees get discount for like the place at work, but I don't for the power plant?
You look like you're having one of your trademark adventures.
Danger!
Mr. Burns!
Mini cameras!
Black Vans!
Oh, good thing I'm drunk.
Stupid drunk.
Oh no!
Won't somebody think of the children?
Acho, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Beat Smitters to Mr. Burns' mansion?
Oh, I'm so good at racing cars.
It's okay.
I know what shortcuts are.
Ooh, the vibration's tickling my feet.
All right, don't worry.
I can beat him.
I don't know where exactly it is, but I can beat him.
I know all the shortcuts.
Hey, where are the shortcuts?
There you go.
Shortcut one.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
I know all the shortcuts, guys.
Shortcut two.
Oh, what?
Wait, I went over!
Ow, my head!
All right, nice trick.
Okay, I'm a little closer now.
Ow, my head!
All right, don't worry.
I know shortcut number three.
Somewhere.
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe I still have to drive.
Guys, maybe I actually have to open my eyes, guys.
Okay, I know the cemetery doesn't work.
All right, nice.
Following the rules.
That's not fair!
Why can't I do that to him?
It's fine.
That's fine.
All right, maybe I should have got the rocket car when everybody was yelling at me to get the rocket car.
Where the fuck does Burns live?
I don't know where my boss lives.
Okay, he's not gonna use this shortcut.
Yippee!
All right, that is the only shortcut I- Guys, confession.
That is the only shortcut I know.
Is it here or the right side?
I can't tell.
All right, this way.
And I assume it's this way.
I don't know where he lives.
Why would I know where my boss lives?
Workday ends...
Ends when work is over.
Wait, what the fuck?
How did he get there before me?
Oh no.
I'm trying to figure out where he lives.
Okay, it's this way.
And then it should be this way.
Oh my god, he's literally right behind me.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
No, not the stupid school bus!
Kids, get out of the way!
This is more important!
All right, I got there.
Mr. Burns!
Oh, sorry.
He called me.
Thank you, Mr. Chad.
Thank you.
Turkey says she has a license.
I big doubt.
Huh?
Release the hounds.
And if this oaf is an employee of the plant, fire him at once.
Oh.
No, I'm not an employee there.
I did it, guys!
I 100% completed the level!
Guys, does it look like I completed it 100%, guys?
Does it look like that?
Low-level employee harasses...
Point on Bart, now.
Hello!
He won't expose me!
Avoid Prince Drive to the Trion City before time runs out?
In what car?
I can drive?
Oh, what's this glowing over here?
Oh, money.
Yay!
Money!
I love money.
Oh, it's my rocket car!
Nice.
I have my own car.
See, if Bart can drive, so can I.
Sorry.
All right, let's jump over this.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Wait, what am I supposed to do?
Oh, I'm supposed to die!
Oh, I'm supposed to make sure he doesn't get me.
He doesn't touch me, okay.
All right, give me a sec.
I'm trying to run around as much as I can.
There's Pauls everywhere!
Why does the mayor keep spending money on hookers?
Oh, he doesn't know I'm right here.
He's so confused.
I've lost him.
Oh no.
Oh no, he's getting closer, isn't he?
It's okay.
It's okay, everything is fine!
He doesn't know where I am!
It's okay, I can fix my car!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, um...
It's okay, the cops don't know.
Oh.
Stop there!
Why are the cops just there?
What are they doing here?
Go fix the fucking potholes!
All right.
Try and save.
Off to try and save I go, I guess.
Where is it?
Where's the try and save?
Try and save?
I'm gonna save my money if I don't know where it is.
Oh, I drove like the long way.
Think of them as little horses.
All right.
We're almost there.
The moment I figure out how to drive in the straight line, we're almost there.
Holy shit, it's so far!
Wait, this map is a lot bigger than I expected for a very old game.
Oh, nice!
Hello, Jimbo.
Okay, I should fix my car.
Give me a sec, Jimbo.
Truckasaurus.
One month only.
Always wanted to like watch like those truck shows.
Like the destroy- like truck destroying shows.
Oh, money!
Free money!
If the money touches the floor, it's free.
I'm pretty sure I can't- Oh, shit!
Oh, I thought I could play it.
What are you gonna do?
Call the cops?
That's right.
What are you gonna fucking do, Jimbo?
Where's your mom now, huh?
You're gonna bully me?
That's fucking right!
Oh, fuck.
Um, let's talk.
Last game, four-finger discount.
Some crazy lady destroyed all the rest.
When will they learn?
Video games don't kill people.
They just kill their minds.
Yeah!
I am the king!
I did it!
Look at that.
That's right.
The cops won't save you now.
That's fucking right.
Who's gonna save you now?
No one!
The cops work for me.
Oh, wait.
I locked- I soft locked him.
He's unkickable now.
Oh, just cause- oh, now you're back to kick zone.
That's right.
You should've stayed in that zone.
You should've stayed there and get soft locked.
Oh, shit.
Give me your taxi.
Don't worry, you can't catch me.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no!
My money!
No!
I mistimed it!
You think I learned my lesson?
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
I haven't learned shit.
I now know I can afford the police by talking to you.
That's right.
I kicked too close to the side.
Okay, weapons of- weapons of mass delinquency.
Collect fireworks from around Springfield before time runs out.
Avoid Chief Wiggum's.
I mean, I've been doing really good at avoiding- At avoiding cops, guys.
Shouldn't be that bad.
Okay, I gotta go to Moe's.
Give me your car, lady.
Alright, we go this way.
Off to see my dad at Moe's.
Alright, here I go.
I think I'm a very good driver after this game.
Alright, here we go.
And then I guess- I mean, we could go this way.
Oh, what does auto want?
Oh, I don't know.
Hello, auto.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I got the fireworks.
Is my dad here?
Hey, Moe.
Hello, Moe.
Talk to me.
I want to talk to you.
Oh, hell yeah.
Yay!
More fireworks!
Let's see...
Where do I go next?
Springfield Town Hall?
Does the mayor sell fireworks, too?
How deep does this firework corruption go?
If I can't even trust the mayor, who can I trust?
No!
No way!
Corrupted politicians?
Say it ain't so!
Oh no, I just need to talk to a criminal.
That's...
That's alright.
Let me talk to a criminal real quick.
Yeah, he's just a criminal.
Alright, let us pick this real quick.
There we go.
And we got the wasps, too.
Alright.
We're out.
Okay, police station.
Wait, there's...
Why would you sell in front of the police station?
Oh, they're at the place you least expect it.
I get it.
The police will never look near the police station for illegal activities.
That's so smart.
It's like...
They're like at the place you least expect.
Yeah, they'll just think everybody will do legal things there.
Not illegal stuff.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, does Ralph have fireworks?
Hello, Ralph.
Oh, your dad's there.
What do you want to do, Ralph?
Well, my daddy might also be going to jail with the stuff he does, so...
Oh yeah?
Give me your car!
Oh, wait.
Oh yeah?
Give me your car!
Oh, I can't steal his car.
That's bad.
This is bad.
Okay, wait.
Wait, he doesn't chase me unless I get in a car.
What if I never get in a car?
Oh, a black van pizza delivery.
Okay, look.
It's good, guys.
As long as I don't get in a car, he can't catch me.
Wait, can I kick his car and it'll explode?
Smart move.
Yeah, I'll just walk across the city.
Wait.
Guys, there's a sprint button?
Guys, I'll just walk back home, guys.
I can walk home.
All right, clearly, clearly my sprint button is not binded to any...
Oh my god!
What is this?
It's not binded to anything.
Okay, what's...
Okay, now I have J button too.
Oh my god!
I could have...
I could have ran a little bit faster.
Can't catch me!
Coppers!
That's fucking right!
If I just run back home...
This is game-changing, guys.
You can't catch me if I run back.
Look at the speed.
I'm almost as fast as a car.
You'll never catch me.
You have no legal right to arrest me when I'm not in a car.
You can only...
New slow running strategy.
Run, Forrest, run!
That's right!
Move along, ladies!
Exactly, it's hit and run.
I'm merely running in my hit and run game.
Yeah, they were jaywalking.
I was just doing what the law couldn't.
Also, I don't know where I'm supposed to go.
I may or may not have to get in the car now.
Don't worry, I'll steal this car.
Wait, I did it!
I did it!
I just had to...
I finished the mission!
That's all I had to do.
That's right, I'm a big brain.
See?
No one could understand my thought process.
It's way beyond anybody's mind.
Car jacked by a 10-year-old.
And I'll do it again!
And I missed.
All right.
Speedrunners in shambles.
I want this comic book guy one.
Hello.
Hey, Jabba the Fat, do you know where I can get a copy of Bonestorm 2?
Yes, I have no time to converse with you.
I must be the first to register my disgust on the internet regarding the numerous films.
The action was dismal and the nudity was frustratingly fleeting.
I barely got through.
Only it had more nudity.
Yes, I suppose.
But must we call it that?
Race the nerd to the Java server?
But where's my car?
Wait, why am I...
Oh, oh!
I have to race him!
Okay.
Oh, the other nerd!
I was like, wait, why am...
Wait, I'm the nerd though.
But there's more than one nerd?
I thought there's a nerd limit in this town.
Oh no, if only I was outside my car and running over right now.
Oh, fuck.
You know, like, comic book guy now has a wife and a child.
If he can get a wife and a child, so, like, it's possible for anyone.
Yeah, and he got a hot Japanese wife, too.
Wait, I lost the race?!
It's so close!
Yeah, in the newest season, he has a hot Japanese wife.
And a child.
Bro, how the fuck do I win this race?
Okay, there's no way for me to win this race, like...
How?
He's so fast!
No!
If I'm not crashing...
What kind of driver do you think I am?
Now you're gonna tell me to not breathe.
Bro, it's not fair!
He's cheating!
My beautiful skull.
This sucks.
I'm out of here.
Yeah, and then the wife chased after him, too.
You're right, if he could get a hot wife, I can win this race.
It's possible.
I have to follow traffic rules to win a race?
What the fuck's the point?
Wait, he's not following traffic rules?!
Yeah.
Wait a minute!
I was lied to!
I didn't have to be an upstanding citizen!
Okay.
This is fair.
No, no, no!
I'm almost there!
I did it!
Nice.
What?
No!
I got scalped!
I gotta play video games now!
No!
Now I have to be a productive citizen?
A productive student?
And do well in school?
What's the point?
What's the fucking point?
I'm gonna beat up the elderly.
If I can't get my video games...
I'll start beating up the elderly.
Give me my video games or this guy gets it!
I get one more kick.
All right, I gotta...
Guys, I don't... I need to stop getting caught by the police so I can afford other cars.
Of course, it's Moe, man.
No one's gay for Moe, man.
No one will miss him!
Just give me a sec.
I need to check my sound.
All right.
Where's my car?
Dude, where's my car?
Oh, there it is.
All right, time... I don't remember.
Oh, time to head to the movie theater.
Frank,
give me my movie or game!
Give me my game!
Right now!
I know you have no family!
I'm here for my game!
Oh, the screen's frozen?
Let me fix that.
Sorry, tab down to run over Professor Frank.
Give me a sec.
I'm fixing it right now.
Is it back?
No!
I can't fix it.
Don't worry, I'll fix it.
All right, uh...
It should be fixed now?
All right, is it fixed?
Oh my god, game.
Come on, game.
He missed out on me running him over!
No!
I have to restart!
Okay, don't worry.
I broke my car, but it's okay.
It's so dark, Doki.
It's so very dark, please.
I just wanna see Simpsons hit and run!
We all do, guys!
I'll save game.
I'll save game, reboot it.
All right, save.
Save successful.
It's just us and the boy.
All right, exit.
All right, launch.
And then they're like, oh, I just can't tab out.
Oh, I just can't tab out, I think.
It should...
It should work now?
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, I just can't tab out.
That's so weird.
If I tab out the...
There you go.
I'm back where I am.
All right, get over here.
Give me my video game!
I don't want to study!
I don't want to go to college!
I got a degree to not do my job!
Get over here!
That's right, what are the police gonna do?
You think the police is gonna save you?
Watch this.
Wait, get up, get up, get up, get up.
No!
I'm mad now!
You think the police is gonna save you again?
That's fucking right!
Ain't gonna save shit!
Get over here!
Just because I paid a $50 fine, you think I learned my lesson?
That's fucking right, nerd!
Get over here!
You think the police can help you again?
That's fucking right!
Oh my god, let me talk.
My latest invention slash monster if you find me a world war ii communication radio and a satellite Then my creation will live and we can play with it and enjoy the frolicking.
Oh cool Real violence is way better than tv violence.
Oh my god, you're right Now who would have a world war ii radio?
That guy that sells all those grenades to nelson might I better check Oh my god, he's so right why escape reality when I can be in reality Follow this guy.
Wait.
I don't have a car.
Yoink my car right now Don't worry I got you Wait, where is he?
All right, where is he going?
I thought to go to the shady guy.
Why did I follow the pizza van now?
Where did this mission come from?
All right, where are you going?
Wait, where is he going?
Well, he's just he's behind me.
Wait, he's following me Come on, get over here
All right, here I go Where are you going?
Why are you going so far?
I know.
I I don't know.
It told me to follow and i'm a good soldier good soldier follows orders I don't even know why i'm following it Literally was like you have to go to the world war ii shop.
I was like, okay, never mind.
Follow this car He's just delivering pizza, why are we bothering him?
Where is he going sir, where are you going sir?
Oh, it's still at the world.
Wait, what it's still up back at the military place Hello wiggum What are you gonna do call your friends?
That's right.
You're gonna call your police friends.
That's fucking right wiggum You're you have no power here That's right Get up, get up, get up, get up, get up Didn't you hear herman's been robbed Hey, you don't know who did it.
Yeah, right.
If you did boy, that would be great Why would they do a world war ii memorabilia these fresh skid marks leading away from the scene of the crime could be a clue But who's to say really?
Wait, what how?
No, it's your fault.
It's your fault.
I talked to you.
I should be safe.
What do you mean?
I should be safe
I don't understand.
How did I still get busted?
I Know what it is except from the law The fear
Why didn't you talk longer If you talk longer i'd be safe i'm mad i'm gonna steal your car Wait, I can't even steal your car Get over here, I lost a hundred I lost two hundred dollars i'm mad now Get over here.
Nobody will save you Just talk long enough.
So the police don't know Get up, get up Um, do I know you little dude?
I need that radio you borrowed.
No way little dude This radio is going to help me score boku day chicks Uh last time I checked the police radio Electronics, there's no women in the in the springfield police Don't have a cow man.
Oh, no.
No, please.
No, I got out
It's not fair I had the police after me.
Why didn't you talk long enough?
It's not fair I kick one person and now I and that's a bad thing Apparently just because I kicked one person.
I have to get arrested How did you I keep accidentally getting out of my car.
I don't know why it's like second nature.
I just want to run instead of drive
I Just can't help it don't you ever just want to run instead of drive like it's just second nature to me Where is this?
Oh, it's over here.
Wait, I think i'm faster I thought this was a free country I'm, not allowed to just kick people for fun One little assault and you get arrested like what is this?
I like to speak to my lawyer All right, let me steal your car Where's your car dude, where's your car?
Wait, he disappeared.
Oh, wait, there he is Nothing is free here.
All right Guys, I don't think i'm gonna be able to please afford anything else because I keep getting arrested I keep accidentally committing crime on accident too Like I don't understand I committed one felon and then I and then I marked as a criminal Like what happened to like boys will be boys It was just an accident
All right I can make it Oh my god, I made it.
I accidentally committed one felony, and then I'm marked as a bad person.
What happened to the justice system?
You actually made it, wow.
Huh?
Let the flat meat before times runs out, avoid a poo?
Why does he like it?
I'm just cleaning the environment.
Move out of the way!
Get out, beep beep!
Where's that poo?
I thought he doesn't like it.
It's okay, I'm cleaning the environment.
I'm cleaning the streets.
If I didn't start eating them, who would in society?
What would the people do if I didn't pick them up?
I'm literally doing community service right now.
Oh no, please.
Move out of the way!
I have the right of law!
There we go.
And then there's another skunk over here.
Yay!
But how do I get out of here?
Oh, there it is.
There's a surprisingly a lot amount of skunks in Springfield.
Wait, 20 seconds?
You didn't even give me that much time to collect them!
13, 12, 13.
Okay, I need one more.
Where's the last skunk?
It won't matter if Quimby Heath votes for you.
Deliver the skunk meat to the Krusty Burger?
You know what?
If we're able to eat horse meat, we can eat skunk meat too.
I've always wanted to try roadkill.
Like, I'm just wondering... Okay, but if you cook it enough...
Because like, the thing about roadkill is that you're worried about bacteria, right?
And I guess rabies.
But can you cook the rabies out?
Is it possible?
Because like, if you cook something enough, it kills the bacteria, right?
So like, can you cook the parasites and rabies out of the meat?
And you cook it long enough?
And you boil it long enough?
I don't have sleep for this.
Bullshit.
I'm just saying.
It's good for the environment because you're not wasting food.
Oh shit, I have nine seconds.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, six.
No, no, it's on the other side!
No!
Please, I'm broke!
I'm broke!
Please!
I have no money!
Oh, I did it.
Okay, but I'm still being... I'm still being chased by the police.
That's fine.
The Krusty Krab is right here.
That's okay.
Okay, if parasites lay eggs, I can just cook the eggs dead, right?
As long as I boil the food, the parasites die.
Oh no.
No!
Okay, he can't catch me if I'm in the mission complete.
Oh my god, he disappeared.
Wait, his car's gone.
I don't like the pizza van.
I feel like they're not actually delivering pizza.
I'm not sure though.
You don't know if it doesn't work or not.
You never tried it.
How would you know you never tried it?
It's all about... science is all about experimenting.
And I'm asking the real questions here.
How have you been able to live this long?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But like...
You don't know if it's okay or not.
You're just too afraid to try it.
You're too stuck in your ways.
Where's my video game?
People have tried it.
Who's people?
Who are they?
Get a blender.
Dr. Nick, he loves blended girl drinks during surgery.
Of course.
Hi, everybody.
Hi, Dr. Nick.
All right, but hillbillies turned out okay.
All I'm saying, they came out just fine.
Where's Dr. Nick?
Dr. Nick!
I need a blender that you use to definitely not blend people.
Hi, Dr. Nick.
Hi, everybody.
You seem like a heavy drinker.
Do you have a blender?
Not now, okay?
My monkeys have escaped.
No, not the monkeys.
I'll be so grateful.
Why won't they come back to you?
Yeah.
I have tortured them horribly.
Oh!
Don't worry.
Everyone will definitely forgive you.
Purchase it from Homer in the hospital parking lot.
No!
Wait, no, I already own.
Wait.
Wait, it's the plow machine.
I already own that, right?
Wait, don't I own that already?
It's the plow machine.
No.
What do you mean getting caught by the police was not it?
Oh, no, he wants a...
What did he... What am I supposed to... Mr. Oh, it's Mr. Plow.
Oh my god, I could just get the plow king.
It's literally that car, but better.
Guys, I think maybe...
Maybe getting caught by the police was not it.
If I knew that getting arrested was a bad idea, I wouldn't have got arrested.
If coins were so important, then why is the legal system around?
Why did they put a legal system in this game?
She's so...
Real for that.
All right.
Let me start kicking things.
Give me your money.
Get over here.
I need 200 coins or your family's gonna die.
Oh, wait, I might lose all the coins I get.
Toki the philosopher.
Hahaha.
Don't worry, I learned my lesson.
I won't get arrested again for the next five minutes.
Please only give me one coin.
It's not fair.
I can kick one person.
Hahaha.
I can kick this.
All right, nice.
That gives me two coins.
There has to be more.
Oh, there's more.
All right, we get this.
There you go.
That should be like at least 200.
I know they should be paying me.
It's an honor to get like being kicked by Toki.
Okay, I need another...
I need another like...
Piece of like Duff Cola or Buzz Cola.
Wait.
I hear...
Oh, no, that's just the surveillance cameras.
I thought I heard something.
Oh, there's more coins there.
Wait.
I can beat the vending machines up.
This is two coins.
And then...
There should be another...
Boom, boom, boom.
All right, that's another...
It's another 170.
All right, and then...
This should be more.
I thought I saw like a box of Duff Cola here or Buzz Cola.
God damn it.
Oh...
I guess...
Ralph Wiggum seems like an easy race.
But then that requires me to try.
Why try when I can just rob people?
Hi, Ralph.
A car?
Pass all checkpoints and don't destroy your vehicle.
All right, this can't be that difficult.
Wait, there's three of them.
That's fine.
My car is faster.
It's fine.
I can... It's fine.
This is salvageable, guys.
This is salvageable.
We can fix this.
Don't worry.
It can't be that fast.
I know all the shortcuts, guys.
Watch this.
I know all the shortcuts.
It's gonna be there soon.
Oh my god.
He's cheating.
I was gonna do that.
Where's the other checkpoint?
Oh, it's over here.
Wait, am I supposed to... Oh, I'm supposed to go up.
Okay.
No, no, no.
We can turn this around.
I...
Wait, I can force them off.
Okay, guys.
Guys, this might be... This might be really difficult.
All right, race this might not be it, guys.
I just need to... Okay, as long as I don't get caught by the police...
Everything will be fine.
I just won it.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
They do it to prevent virus and bacteria transmission from...
bloody prep work.
Wait, what's this?
Do you think they have extra coins?
More contact with humans means a mutation that can infect humans...
reaches us and replicate.
This is how HIV, bubonic plague, COVID, mad cow, bird flu, and etc.
get to us.
Yeah, but like I'm built different.
I survived all of those.
Why don't you have money at the DMV?
No, you are not.
How do you know that, huh?
Wait.
Let's just grab this real quick.
I feel like I might need it.
Get out of here, Krusty.
Okay, we need to buy...
We need to be able to afford the Plow King or Mr. Plow.
Wait, he wants to talk to me.
Hey, hey, Grandpa!
Which war, though?
I didn't think I'd need it.
Collect the blood for Grandpa.
Okay, that's fine.
Wait, if I run over people, then that's... that's easy blood.
Why do I have to collect blood when I can just get it from the people I run over?
No, Toki.
That's free blood!
They're not gonna need it.
They might be dead.
Or an organ... they might be organ donors.
Okay, at least right here.
We can't... we won't find out unless we run them over.
Wait, where's the blood?
Where's my free bag of blood?
Wait, enter bows.
Okay, nice.
Sorry.
Sorry, Grandpa.
I got a new mission.
Yeah, that's just like human blood.
Yay, I did it!
Not so deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Toki.
I'm built different.
Is sick with a cough or worse?
90% of the... yeah, but it wasn't COVID!
Or the bubonic plague!
Um, it's just a regular cold.
Blood!
Only... the only sickness that can get me is weak... the weak sickness.
Okay, wait, I need to grab money from this.
I never got bird flu!
It's just because my body is not good against like...
the cold... the common cold.
It's so common.
It's just too common.
Nice.
More blood.
Okay.
Oh, I just need to take it back to Grandpa.
Grandpa!
I got your legal blood!
Yeah, I'm so strong that I just don't know how to fight the weak because I'm not... my body was never trained for that.
It got... yeah, it's so weak.
It got through my filter.
All right, let's see.
Beep beep.
My 99% human blood for Grandpa.
Grandpa, look!
I got it!
Here you go, Grandpa!
Yay!
Wait, that's a bonus mission!
You've unlocked Grandpa's World War 2 vehicle.
Yippee!
What does it look like?
This deserves to be in a museum, but instead I'm gonna drive in and crash the car!
Hey, Grandpa!
You know, we could be millionaires if we sold this car, but instead let's fucking destroy... let's destroy it actually.
All right, Grandpa.
This is what World War 2 would have wanted.
All right.
Yeah, oh my god, you're right!
Anyone I hit...
Anyone I hit will be in the museum!
Oh no, no!
I just got my money!
No!
Grandpa, run!
I just got... I just got $250!
I forgot about the police!
No, I forgot!
I just got $50!
Don't let him get me!
Please!
I just got $50!
$50!
No!
Grandpa, no!
I just got $50!
I can't!
I can't go back!
I can't go back, Grandpa!
Please!
Please don't make me go back!
Don't make me go back!
Not the money!
Please!
No, I just got out!
No!
Not the money!
Stupid car!
Stupid fucking car!
Explode!
You've been nothing but trouble!
That's right!
You lose money?
What do you mean?
No!
I fixed the car and I fixed Grandpa.
Oh my god!
That's not fair!
I don't want his car anymore!
Why would I lose money?
For exploding a car?
Like, what?
For property damage?
This entire game is property damage!
That's not fair!
Like, who am I giving my money to?
The government?
My actions have consequences?
I'm here to escape reality!
Not give the government my money!
Alright, hey Professor Frank.
I need to drive to the screaming monk.
Oh, I have to do this again?
It like restarted my mission.
Your insurance is going up?
What insurance?
You guys have insurance?
Alright.
Hello everybody!
Where is Homer?
Where is this fatass?
There he is.
What?
Wait, what?
Really?
Okay.
I had to double take that.
I wanted to see what it said.
Alright.
Insane sigh.
I was curious.
I was like, did it actually say what I just saw it said?
Okay.
There has to be like...
There has to be like some areas with some coins somewhere.
Here.
Why didn't anybody stop me?
Guys, why did no one stop me from committing crime?
Okay.
99...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you okay?
Oh my god, you destroyed the phone.
Okay, that's property damage right there.
That's property, that's 200.
There you go, my one coin.
As long as I don't commit...
As long as I don't commit any more crime...
It should be fine.
As long as I don't...
Commit any more crime...
Everything will be okay.
Alright, there you go.
Last crime.
That's fucked up!
I'm just... I'm in elementary school!
Zero dollars.
Collect the monkeys before time runs out.
Then...
Get the blender from Dr. Nick.
Okay.
I gotta get Mr. Plow.
Mr. Plow.
That's my name.
Oh no, it's the crazy monkeys.
How many crazy monkeys are there?
What the fuck, they're everywhere!
Come on, crazy monkeys.
Go back to your abusive owner.
Hey!
That's a lot of monkeys.
Oh my god, there's like 30 of them.
Oh, I can get through this.
Alright, where else?
Hello, crazy monkeys!
Don't worry!
He abuses you because he loves you!
So go back to the crazy monkeys hospital.
Oh shit, nice money.
Lots of money.
Yay!
Alright.
I'm halfway there.
And he really loves you.
Come on, you can trust the doctor.
Yeah, I can't be bothered.
You can live for free, Wasp.
You'll get to live there.
Ba dum.
Wait, can I get out of the car?
I have to be able to, there's no way.
This is literally like, up top.
Alright.
We're almost there, we need 10 more!
10 more!
Alright.
6 more!
Jesus fucking Christ.
This side.
First time I see this side.
5 more!
No!
Get up the stairs!
Come on!
You think stairs will stop my car?
I paid $200 for this.
Alright.
Stairs are meant to be driven up by cars!
They're like little ramps for us.
Alright, one more.
Wait, where's the last monkey?
Ba dum.
Alright, time to put them back into a monkey medical research center.
Don't worry, monkeys!
They're going back home to a very loving and abusive father!
But that's how he shows love!
Hi, Dr. Nick!
Yippee!
They make the brain go happy!
Drive to the stadium?
Okay, back to the stadium I go.
Alright.
Time to give Professor Frank the...
a blender!
Oh, it's right here!
Nerd spotted.
And that's bad.
Why?
Just...
Just say you didn't do it!
Destroy all the cell phone users' cars before time runs out?
Alright, let me get water real quick.
I'll be right back, guys!
I ran out of water!
I gotta stay hydrated if I want to commit more...
illegal crimes.
Hey, I'm back!
Don't worry.
I learned my lesson.
I know what to do when the cops come.
Watch this.
Guys, this is what I'll do when the cops come.
Watch.
Get over here.
I'm gonna use you as an example.
Get over here, nerd!
That's right!
Get your ass over here!
Watch this, guys.
Can't catch me.
I'm not on it.
I'm not in a car.
That's right!
Oh, you think you can catch me now?
Oh, that's right!
Okay,
he can catch me.
Oh shit, my mission!
I forgot I have a mission to do.
Oh shit, okay.
I thought I juked him.
Alright.
I forgot I have an actual mission to do.
I was too busy trying to prove a point.
Alright.
I thought...
I thought the car would just be too fast.
You know?
God damn it.
What the fuck?
Why are you driving away?
Alright.
Look, I almost got away, guys.
Okay, I can do this in 20 seconds.
Come on.
Collapse on me.
Come on!
Do more damage!
Why is it not doing any damage?
Oh, I should have bought a better car.
I just realized it's because I have a regular car.
I should have got Mr. Plow in here.
No!
Alright, let me grab Mr. Plow.
Okay, wait, I can do this with this car.
Watch.
There we go.
And then...
Fuck.
I thought he...
I thought he ran at me again!
Okay, we need Mr. Plow.
It's fine.
I'll do what Mr. Plow quoted.
Destroy a car.
Oh!
One more ram!
There we go.
I did it.
Wait, I have to do another car?
How many cellphones are in the city?
I thought everybody in Springfield is poor!
Oh, this car is not gonna be okay.
I thought only Mr. Burns and the mayor and also the only doctor...
Actually, no, Dr. Nick is also a doctor.
The two other doctors in the city!
Okay, I need to borrow another car.
Alright, give me a...
Oh!
Um,
rest in peace to that guy that died.
Thoughts and prayers, guys.
Thoughts and prayers.
Okay, you should turn around here.
So yeah, borrow another car.
Alright, get over here!
Oh no, two minutes.
Oh no.
It's okay.
Fuck!
Get over here, please!
Please, you don't understand!
My dracones are watching!
Wait, I'll intercept him here.
He won't expect it.
I did that much damage for interception?
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
I think he knows, guys.
Oh no, my money!
It's okay.
Wait, this is an unlimited money glitch!
It gives me more money than it takes!
It's an actual unlimited money glitch!
I just gotta keep destroying cars!
Okay, there has to be life.
Let me borrow your car.
Should show up here.
There you go.
I found the loophole, guys!
Come on.
Come on, crash into something!
Come on, you just need to crash in one more time!
Come on, get over here!
You don't need that car!
Oh shit.
Please, literally just one hit.
There we go.
I have to destroy another one?!
Alright, don't worry.
I figured it out.
There we go.
I know the pathway now.
I know his pathing.
He's gonna go this way, and then I go this way, and then he does a u-turn, and then I go this way, and I'll meet him on the other side.
I know his pathing now.
And then I go...
Boom!
There we go.
And I know where he's gonna go next, which is here.
No!
My car!
Where did he go?
I think he's gonna go here.
I actually don't know where he's gonna go.
Oh, he follows traffic laws!
Oh no, he doesn't.
Come on!
Yes!
No!
My car!
Alright.
See, I get more than I lose.
I'm at like 50 coins now.
Alright.
We go again.
God, how many cars are there?
Okay, I know where he goes.
He's gonna go here, and I'm gonna go here, and I'll meet him on the other side.
Wait.
Wait, there's no other side.
I'm gonna meet him over here.
I'll meet him on the other side.
Nice.
Okay.
And then, he goes that way, so I go this way.
That's right.
And then he goes that way, so I go this way.
Wait, okay, that's not it.
He goes that way, so I lost my sense of direction.
So I go this way.
And I'll meet him here.
There we go.
See, guys?
I can read a map.
And then he goes that way, and I go faster than him.
Come on.
Bump into that.
Yes!
I did it.
Yippee!
I destroyed all the cars.
See, it's legal crime.
If the police didn't come and stop me, and the police didn't arrest me, then everything I did was legal.
So...
Alright, time to go home.
Yippee!
Oh, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, there's a nerd.
Hello.
Nerd?
What if I...
What if...
Okay, but like...
I blame his computer navigation system.
Jump the lightspeed!
See, he's okay.
He's okay, guys.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do I get...
Okay, if I get more than $50, it's an unlimited money glitch.
My coins are gone.
My coins despawned!
No!
Cause I looked away!
Guys, it was an unlimited money glitch, guys.
It wasn't.
It wasn't an unlimited money glitch.
What?
Who is that?
A truck-in-saurus?
Don't worry, I can drift.
I did it!
I lived!
Dude!
That song was written by Michael Jackson.
Supposedly.
Wait, what?
Aliens?
I didn't mute myself.
I'm blowing my nose.
Rare Doki moment.
There's aliens in my game?
Yes, please.
Alright, now I should be Lisa, right?
Hello, I'm Lisa.
Do I have enough money?
To afford anything?
Oh, I have...
Oh no, not Florida!
Oh, I have cool Lisa.
I wanna be Florida Lisa!
Alright, guys.
I will save my money for real now.
Guys, I swear to God.
Oh my God!
Who the fuck died in there?
Do I need to call somebody for that?
Itchy and Scratchy Kiss?
Where's the nerd?
Get the comic book before time runs out.
Oh my God, my fanfiction.net!
It's real!
Oh fuck, okay.
These nerds are so good at driving.
Oh no, not the cops!
Please, I need to save money for real!
I need to buy Florida!
Please, if I lose the race, I'll be safe.
I just need to lose the race, guys.
Guys, it'll be fine.
As long as I lose the race.
Then I won't be caught.
You can't catch me!
If I lose the race, please!
Please, how far away is this race?
Why are we still racing?
Oh, I'm safe.
Oh, now I lost the race.
Okay, alright.
Now I lost the race.
That's cool.
That's alright, I guess.
That's alright.
There's no way I lose money if I lose the race!
This is part of the mission!
It's part of the campaign!
Oh my god, where are the shortcuts in this area?
Okay, this one has to be a shortcut, right?
Yeah.
What?!
I got tollbooth?!
Oh my god, oh my god, I missed the shortcut.
I missed the shortcut, there was a shortcut over there.
I missed it.
I got so confused.
Oh my god, there it is!
Wait, what?
It was right here all along, why'd it take it forever?!
Okay, I got first place though.
It's fine.
I'm first.
Finally.
The writers knew exactly what I wanted.
Alright, here I go.
This way.
Oh, jazz!
The jazz hole.
My favorite type of hole.
This way.
I heard there's a mod that makes all the maps interconnected, which I thought was pretty cool.
And there's like a Spongebob mod.
Yay!
Haha!
Ah, yes.
The perfect business expense.
Alright, drive to the Noiseland Arcade.
Wait, what are my cars?
What are Lisa's cars?
Lisa, what car do you own?
I need to know.
Dr. Milhouse?
I don't know about that.
Oh, I have a Malibu Stacy car?!
Oh, that's cute!
Book Burning Van?!
Alright, I want my...
Where's my Malibu Stacy car?
Wait, where is it?
There it is.
Do I entertain Milhouse?
Oh my god, guys.
Two dried toppings.
Holds two of them?!
Follow Ms. Milhouse's clues to find Bart.
Don't let time run out.
Okay, but I just need to get in the vehicle, right?
Alright, but I need some cash, some moolah real quick.
Free money!
I need Florida.
I need to buy Florida, guys.
Don't understand.
When else can you buy Florida?
Okay.
Wait, it's just that?
I could've walked!
This was a walking mission, Milhouse.
Wait.
Florida.
I understand.
Yeah.
Wait, Maggie?
Maggie, are you okay?
Maggie!
What's going on, Maggie?
You don't look so good!
That's like ten whole polygons!
What?
Did I?
Oh, whoops.
Now I don't feel as guilty anymore.
Babies love the ball pit.
Yeah.
It's alright.
If I can't see her, I don't feel as guilty.
That's how it goes, right?
Out of sight, out of mind.
Exactly!
If I don't see it, nothing bad happens.
Alright, where do I have to go?
It's like Planet Hype or something?
This way.
Oh my god, it's the Mr. Burns Casino!
Wait, I thought they destroyed it.
Oh, shit.
For some reason, I thought I could drive over it.
Yeah, it was just an accident.
Who would ever push that lever?
Oh shit, eight seconds.
I was doing a leisurely drive.
It's okay, it's right here.
Again?
Yeah, you creep!
Aww, he's just trying to get...
date night.
Like, five seconds of date night.
I know your plans, Milhouse.
Taking me to all these romantic spots for five seconds.
It's not a date, Milhouse!
The indirect kiss.
Oh shit, oh shit.
The coppers might get me.
Don't worry.
What are you doing on my road?
This is not pedestrian lane!
Get away!
Move!
This is the lane for cars!
See?
It transitioned into the road.
So this is a car lane.
Everything is coming.
No, it's called a board road.
I don't know where you get these ideas.
Move out of the way!
I have the right of law!
Oh shit.
I was driving too leisurely again.
I need to stop doing that.
Please, please.
Oh my god, I just made it!
Oh shit, there's Milhouse.
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
Exactly, it's a board drive.
Can I...
Wait, how do I talk to him now?
Wait.
Wait, I fucked up.
Oh, there he goes.
There he goes.
Wait, that means I can do that again.
Come on, get down.
Oh no, an accident happened, guys.
What do I do?
Oh no.
Somebody please save him.
An accident happened.
Oh, see, he's okay.
Oh no, guys, another accident.
Don't worry, I do that...
and he's back.
Where is he?
The Harvest Dance?
Yeah,
Fortnite emoted on Milhouse.
Alright, maybe Appu knows where he is.
Alright, Krusty Burger.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, it's this way.
The amount of times he comes in clutch at the last second is amazing.
Everything coming up for Doki.
Let's thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nothing ever goes wrong for her.
Alright.
I love the music for this game.
It's just classic Simpsons.
Oh shit.
Please, I just wanna be able to afford Florida.
Oh!
I can kick those.
I need Florida.
No!
This is so cruel.
They barred it away from me.
That's so fucked up.
They know what I want.
They're dangling all that money in front of me.
Don't eat beef ham, ahoy.
That's so messed up.
How could they just dangle all that delicious money in front of me like that?
How could they just do that to me?
So close, yet so far.
Oh my god, I'm so close.
I need 100 more coins.
Alright, Appu.
What do you want?
No!
How could they do such a thing?
How could they ruin this small business?
Are they racist?
Get outta here!
How could they?
How could they harm these small businesses like this?
Oh wait, wrong car.
Oh wait, no, I still hit him.
Nice.
Alright.
Wait, he has such a nice car.
Wait, maybe your business does not- Wait a minute.
Is your business not as small as I thought it was?
How the fuck are you able to have such a nice car?
You know what?
How dare they ruin a medium-sized business like Appu.
Wait.
Nice.
Holy shit, how am I supposed to do like 15?
Also, to be fair, how much does Appu fucking make?
I just realized he has 8 children.
He has 8 couplets.
And a lovely arranged marriage wife.
Please, I need- Please, I only have a minute.
Please.
Please, I only have a minute.
Keep- Please.
Drop some more roadkill.
Get over here.
Wait, what?
That was a hit!
Give me the meat!
Oh no, I don't think I'm gonna make it, guys.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Oh no.
I need 3 more!
Please, please!
13!
No!
The closest!
Drop the meat for the love of God!
Please.
I locked him in!
Okay, I locked him in!
But where did he go?
But I locked him in!
How did he get out?
Oh no.
Come on, give me!
Please!
Why did he have to do this on the highway?
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it this time.
I am 1 minute in and I only have 4.
Oh no.
I'm on the wrong side of the road!
God damn it.
This is a lot harder.
He's not dropping as much.
Keep dropping them!
Maybe stay on the right lane?
Look.
Why would they make 4 lanes if I wasn't allowed to drive on all 4 of them?
What's the point of having 4 lanes?
Here we go.
That's 4 open roads for me.
All for me.
Drop them!
Drop the meat!
Drop!
Guys, I don't think I made it.
I don't...
No!
This one's a lot harder.
Okay.
Here we go.
That should be another one.
Alright, alright.
I got the strat in.
I got the strat, guys.
I got the strat this time.
It's fine.
I figured it out.
There we go.
That's another one.
Fuck.
Okay.
There we go.
I got the strat in.
I'm blocking him.
I'm meat blocking him.
No!
You're supposed to be blocked!
Alright.
Fuck!
No, no, no.
This is a war.
There's no rules in war.
Here we go.
Come on, drop another one.
Drop another one!
Grab it to me!
Come on, I need more!
More meat!
That's right!
Keep dropping them!
Okay, now I'm just helping him go faster.
Here we go.
That should be another one.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh my god, I got... I got... Wait, what?!
He's dropping them all!
It's raining roadkill!
Come on.
Just two more.
Alright.
Here we go.
One more, one more!
Wait, where is he?
And I was like, wait.
Here we go.
Oh my god, we did it.
It's raining meat.
Alright, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tokyo is the best tribe I've ever seen.
Matthew Murdock.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Come again.
Wait.
Money?
Money.
Free money.
Alright, stay here.
Oh shit, it's time!
I keep forgetting.
Please, Appu, I need money to buy Florida.
That's all I wanted.
It's every girl's dream to own Florida.
No time for that.
But it's every girl's dream.
I just want to own Florida.
Oh hey, there's one of the crazy monkeys.
From Dr. Nick.
Oh my god, it's him!
Oh my god, it's a scratchy bot!
Why does he have a scratchy bot?
Yeah, where is he?
Oh, did he got raptured?
Yeah!
It's me, the lizard queen!
I need to talk to someone wise.
Let's go to get Grandpa.
Surely he knows what's up.
Okay, now I'm gonna go get money.
I need money.
Where money can be exchanged for goods and services.
Wait, where's Grandpa?
He's right here.
Wait a minute.
Wait, Grandpa, what are you doing here?
I thought to explore to find you, Grandpa.
Explain how.
I better use something big if I wanna take that car out.
Digi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here, money.
No!
I want it in Florida!
Florida!
I have to buy a school bus?
What about Florida?
Florida!
That is not fair.
Weepking, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When did Simpsons become GTA?
Always has been.
I'm sad.
Oh shit, oh shit.
Oh no, I've become a car.
Alright, that's fine.
I think that car will be okay.
No, I have to... Wait, can I go gambling?
Wait, if I go gambling, I can double my money.
Okay, never mind.
Let's not go gambling.
It's okay.
Guys, it's just that easy.
Let's quit gambling, guys.
Just click no.
Wait, where did he go?
He's so far up.
Oh my God, it's $300?
Oh my God.
It's like, maybe I shouldn't have got arrested like six times.
Maybe I should've...
Maybe I should've saved money.
How was I supposed to know, guys?
That money would be important.
Who would've known?
Eating, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh no, no, no, my coins, my coins.
Alright.
Basic economics.
I thought it was like a collectible, you know?
Eat, um, here's ten dot bucks to aid in the acquisition of Florida to the Jokey Shrine.
Bet it all on red.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Leto, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Guys, I need a hundred more coins, guys.
Oh my God, why did I...
Oh look, it's OIDAMCAPCRUSTY!
I thought they closed that shit down.
I'm broke, Gato.
Can I have a student discount, please?
Just a student... just a student discount.
Alright, I need a hundred more.
It's okay, as long as the car doesn't actually explode, we'll be fine.
Wait, where am I?
Oh my God, the walk all the way back.
I seem to be stranded here, can you help a sister out?
Okay, I need to kick this guy.
Nice, alright, more money.
I don't know, I thought I'd go into, like...
I thought I'd see, like, I don't know, a little Jimmy that got fell down the well.
How was I supposed to know it'd take me back here?
Alright, it's fine.
As long as I don't get arrested, then everything should be okay.
Surely, I'll stay out of trouble this time.
You know, it only takes me getting arrested six times to know when to not break the law.
Alright, nice.
Alright, get over here.
Okay, that should be, like, almost a hundred.
Okay, 70, 81.
What the fuck?
What is that?
Oh, no.
Oh my God, that's a dead pig.
For only one dollar?!
Damn.
Economy sucks these days.
Yay, campfire!
Oh, why is it glowing?
It's cause it's like a little Easter egg.
Every time.
Yeah, that's right, Lord.
I can't, guys.
I have to buy a bus.
I have to buy a bus, guys.
They won't let me.
Wait, can I run this over?
Oh, no.
Guys, I can't let this car explode.
I'm gonna abandon this car now, so it'll never explode.
Okay, there is, like, a little opening here.
Alright, that should be, like...
It should have, like, another ten dollars here.
Welp, I'm too short.
No, why must I have a body of a child?!
Let me kick you!
Okay, that should be a hundred.
I need to save up 200 more for Florida.
Where does this take me?
Where am I?
Nice!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, my dream is gonna come true!
Never give up, guys.
Never give up, and then you can buy the state of Florida.
Never give up!
Don't let your dreams become dreams!
Alright.
All I have to do is just...
Oh, shit.
It's okay, I got 30 dollars from that.
Alright, got the school bus.
Okay, I just need 200 dollars.
Alright, let's see.
Hello?
I need that school bus.
Alright, don't worry.
My IQ is 120, so I'm legally allowed to drive a school bus.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
I feel like IQ tests are a scam, though, to be fair.
Oh, wait.
I already... Okay.
Destroy the black sedan to find a clue.
Don't let time run out.
Alright, I got the bus, though.
Alright.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, collect Bart's lucky hat?
Oh, now to destroy it.
Oh, fuck.
Please!
I spent my Florida money for this!
Let me destroy you!
That's all I asked for!
I only want one simple thing.
Crashing your car into this dam.
That's all I wanted.
Just one thing.
One tiny thing.
Can you not do that for me?
I don't ask for much.
Nice.
Yay, crime!
Yay, he's dead.
Alright, there must be... Oh, I might be able to get money here.
Okay.
Every time!
Every time, just like, but money!
Get back in your car, Doki!
This is hit and run!
Alright, okay.
Okay, game.
I guess I'll get back in the car.
Alright.
Alright, here I go.
I have to go downstairs.
Downtown.
I'm at the Aztec Theater.
Oh wait, another one?
Where's he going?
No.
What?
Okay, I was not expecting that.
Wait, that's not fair!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Can't get me!
That's right!
Wait, there's a cop over there.
Wait a minute.
No, no, no, no, no.
I can't.
Please.
Please, I saved so much money.
Please!
It can't do this to me!
I saved so much!
This car is so beefy!
It's so hard to drive this car!
No, no, no.
Please, please, please.
I don't care.
I don't care!
Oh my god, okay.
It's fine.
I just gotta slam the car once.
And then he should be out of it.
Okay, where is he though?
It's okay.
As long as I slam this car once, it should be fine.
Wherever this car is.
Okay, I just need to find him.
Okay, apparently it's not just once, guys.
Apparently it's not just once.
It's alright.
It's okay.
I can do this again.
That's fine.
I just gotta push him up the ramp.
Push him up against another car.
That's right.
I can do this forever.
I just need another car to hit you.
Alright, here we go.
Get over here!
Boom!
Alright, nice.
Alright, that's fine, Lisa.
You're never going to college anyway.
You're never gonna age up for college.
If anything, you just get a scholarship money.
That's okay.
It's alright, guys.
I'm pretty sure he has life insurance.
It'll be fine.
Alright, nice.
Stop resisting!
Alright, here we go.
Where do I go from here?
Here?
Yeah.
I already forgot where the other cars are.
Alright, there should be another car coming up here now.
Wait, where's the other car?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, no.
JK, I lied.
There it is!
There he is.
Don't worry.
I'll hit him.
Boom!
See, it's that easy.
Get over here!
You think you can get away from me?!
I outdrove the cops!
Get over here!
Oh my god, he's like 1 HP.
Alright, I still have like... nice.
I have drive the planet hype.
Okay, one more.
Alright, one more car.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here!
Oh no.
I only have a little bit more.
I can only run over one more person.
I gotta pick that wisely.
Alright, I got my one.
I got my one.
It's okay, guys.
I can run over one more.
Alright, and then I'll never commit crime again.
Oh shit.
Please!
I can't go back!
I was so close!
Please!
You can't put me back in there!
I can't go back to jail!
No!
I can't get...
I can't!
No, he's gonna... and I'm gonna lose suspicion too!
No.
He's just one hit.
He's just one hit!
Oh my god!
It was one hit!
It was actually one hit!
Oh my god!
I just... I was so close!
It was actually one hit!
What's the point?
We lost $50 for nothing.
What's the... Oh my god!
And then he kills himself!
Why couldn't the other card do that?
He had nothing to live for!
Why couldn't he do that?
Fight the intrusive.
He didn't even give me the kill!
I'm so sad!
Oh my... What's the point?
What's the point?
I'm using the stairs.
Fuck this.
I don't need regular roads.
What's the point?
All my money.
God, there's no point in working hard when you're just gonna get arrested anyway!
What's the point of working hard when the fucking police are gonna frame you for murder and arrest you unjustly?
I didn't do nothing!
I was driving the car!
Just cause I drive the car?
Just cause I'm a woman?
A little girl driving a school bus?
I deserve to get arrested?
I should've gone off the grid.
Why is there so many people there?
How can I legally destroy a car with all these civilians?
What's the point?
How can I legally commit manslaughter with all these people in the way?
Can't even manslaughter in peace!
Florida's forever out of reach.
Road rage.
DIE!
Your life doesn't matter!
Take your life out yourself!
Alright, come on!
Crash into me!
Oh my god!
You're literally one!
Who are you living for and what do you have to live for?
You're one inch big!
I swear to god!
Oh my god, I swear to god, I've touched him like 20 times!
I swear to fucking god, I've touched this car 20- I swear to god, I sw- no, no!
I swear to god!
No way!
No fucking way!
Oh my god!
He actually got away with one inch speed!
What the fuck?
I like hit him!
He hit so- guys, you don't unders- Oh my- I can't, I have to retry this.
I- I can't.
I can't catch up to him.
Oh my god, I don't understand!
How- how did that car survive?
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Alright.
I swear to god, if I see this car fucking explode without me, I swear to fucking god, if this car suddenly explodes without me doing anything else, I swear to fucking god, I swear, I swear, I swear to god, I swear to god, you better not explode without me touching you.
I- I'm watching you.
I'm fucking watching you right now, there we go.
That car's too angry to die.
I swear to fucking god, if this car does not explode- Oh!
Oh!
Hang on by a goddamn thread.
Alright, another car.
Another car.
I'm going straight in.
There we go.
That's right, oh and then he crashes himself.
Why can't- why couldn't other cars be just like you?
You're different.
Where is he going?
Where are you going?
Oh my god.
Yeah, you're not going anywhere, buddy.
You're not going anywhere.
There we go, I get two cars for the price of one?
Let's fucking go.
Nice guys, I got a twofer.
Alright.
I see you.
That's fucking right.
You can't get out of this corner!
That's fucking right!
In a chain corner!
That's right!
You'll never leave!
I did it.
We did it.
You know what?
I deserve a reward.
There we go.
I deserve a reward for that.
With some legal manslaughter.
Alright.
Nice.
That's right, Chief Wiggum.
What are you going to do about it, huh?
That's fucking right.
Nothing!
Yeah.
Yeah?
What kind of disguise?
Wait,
what kind of costume?
You need a disguise purchase?
No!
But...
But I saved all that money!
Not fair!
Like, it's not fair!
Why can't I just buy a state?
Not fair!
A state is meant to be bought.
Look at Alaska.
Florida remains under the sea.
Can't believe it.
I wanted to hold...
You're never too young for coffee, Lisa.
Apparently.
I'm so sad.
I feel like you should be able to legally rob somebody.
For money.
If this is...
This is why this is GTA for kids.
They won't let me rob anyone.
Alright.
Where can I get money?
Why can't I rob these people?
What did I get?
Oh, I got like...
Guys, I don't want to do racing.
Unless it's a mission.
Racing is so hard.
Give me money!
Why can't I steal their money?
What are they gonna do with it?
They're not gonna buy Florida?
Oh, there's money.
There's money.
Wait, there's money here.
How do I get this, though?
Oh my god, my $4.
Let's go.
The final level to this game was brutally difficult?
Wait, what do you mean?
What?
What do you mean?
I'm already struggling.
Wait, how many...
How many levels are there left?
Hey, there's Skinner.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
Oh,
okay.
I mean, might as well, right?
Help Principal Skinner complete his errands before...
You know what?
He's already missing, guys.
He can't be missing for...
I mean, like...
He's already missing, so, like...
So, like...
It's okay if we, like, you know...
Do some errands or so.
He can't go more missing.
What's gonna happen?
Amber Alert?
If anything...
Him being missing longer...
Is better for us.
So then there's an Amber Alert.
So then, we can have, like...
Free search parties.
Ooh, gold stars.
Will that go on my report card?
Isn't that not how it works?
If your child is missing for more than...
X amount of days, an Amber Alert will go off.
Yeah, but then...
Who's gonna murder Bart?
Sideshow Bob?
He's in prison.
And I trust...
I trust Springfield's jail system.
Run by our...
Our beloved chief, Wiggum.
Alright.
Hello.
Ha!
Yay!
MSG!
Wait,
what war would Skinner be in now?
Now that it's 2025?
Cause, like...
Abraham... I won't say Abraham Lincoln.
Abraham Simpson.
Abe is in, like, the Vietnam War.
So, like, what war would he be in?
Oh, he'd be, like, in...
Yeah, I'm like...
Yeah, cause they have to, like...
They have to fix the...
The timeline of everything.
Oh, true.
Oh my god.
We're in...
We're, like, at a time now that, like...
Skinner participated in the Middle Eastern Wars.
Like, that's actually...
Absolutely crazy to think about.
The Simpsons had aired so long...
That, like, Principal Skinner's participant was...
Was in another different kind of war.
No, they fixed him.
Because, like...
The timeline is different now.
Because it's all, like...
They're always, like, changing the timeline.
That they always, like, stay relevant.
They made the new...
The new timeline of the Simpsons.
That Abe was in the Vietnam War.
He's not in World War I and II anymore.
He's in the Vietnam War.
Are you watching the newest episodes?
Alright, time for...
What do I have to do here?
Where am I going?
She's talking about modern Simpsons!
We don't talk about...
Hahaha!
They don't exist here!
You know there's an episode where...
Bart Simpsons becomes a pro gamer...
And he plays League of Legends?
Hahaha!
But, like, the Simpsons League of Legends.
Oh, shit, I'm gonna fail this one.
No!
Hahaha!
It's too busy!
Yeah, there's an episode in the Simpsons...
Where, like, Bart Simpsons...
Becomes, like, an eSports gamer.
And he plays, like...
He plays, like, League.
Hahaha!
Alright, don't worry, I'm heading home.
I'm heading to Darren's.
I was too busy yapping.
Alright.
I need to figure out the shortcuts for this area.
Oh my god.
The time mission is so brutal.
I won't be surprised if there's an episode...
Where Lisa becomes a VTuber.
I will not be surprised.
Because they always do, like...
They always do, like, modern takes of things now.
For episodes.
Let's see.
That's fine.
Stop inventing!
Alright, give me the meat.
Actually, the MSG.
Alright.
I have no idea where, like...
This last one is.
Where's the last mission?
Oh.
Alright.
Oh, I can go down here.
Yay!
Oh, fuck!
I keep forgetting that blocks me.
Alright, nice.
It was just a casino.
Alright.
Hello, Dr. Nick.
That's me!
Oh.
Alright, here's your last thing.
Alright, drive...Wait, what?
I thought you said the next stop was the last stop!
What the fuck?
You lied to a little girl?
That's messed up, yo.
I don't know the shortcuts here!
I don't have my GPS!
Please!
I don't know what's short!
Oh, no.
No, please.
I'm almost there, please!
Please!
No!
It was right there!
Why?
How do I make it?
Oh, my God.
I literally needed one second.
I needed one fucking second.
It's not fair!
Wait, where am I?
Oh, fuck.
I fucked it up.
I already fucked it up.
I forgot where I was.
Oh, my God.
I'm stuck!
It's over.
It's so over.
Driving uphill is the worst.
No!
Not the liberal guilt!
Okay.
I'm driving up the stairs.
Alright.
Here we go.
Recycle!
Thank you for the five gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
Here I go.
You literally said the last mission was the last mission.
You fucking liar!
How could you lie to a little girl?
Oh, my God.
Please.
There has to be a short shortcut.
There has to be a short...
Oh, no.
I...
It's fine.
We made it.
Okay.
Okay, if I parked it in a good way... Okay.
I'll park it.
This is the strat.
I get more time.
Wait!
I got an idea.
The timer doesn't start until I'm in the car.
Until I'm in the car, right?
Wait!
The timer...
Oh, my God.
The timer doesn't start until I'm in the car.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay, here.
You stay here.
You stay here, Skinner.
I'll run back.
I'll...
I have the strat.
Don't worry.
The big brain strat.
Timer doesn't start until I'm in the car.
So that means...
That means I have all the time in the world.
Get into your vehicle.
Don't worry.
I'm heading home.
I figured it out.
That's okay, right?
You don't outsmart me.
That's right, video game.
I make the rules.
Big brain moment.
Surely I have enough time now.
There's no way.
Surely I'll make it now.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Oh no, please.
Please.
I need all the time I need.
I finally used my other brain cells.
Oh my god.
I made it.
You're actually so big brain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Money?
What?
Yay!
I got Skinner's car!
Nice.
I drive Mr. Brun's casino.
Wait, I need money.
Oh my god.
Why couldn't you give me money?
See guys?
He said living body.
I didn't fuck up.
Alright, there has to be money up here, right?
Yeah, I knew it.
I knew it.
I knew there would be money up here.
I need like, what?
200?
Was it 200 or 250?
For the cool outfit.
50 gifted shits!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
I told you.
It's because of that big brain strat, right?
You're like, oh my god, why didn't I think of that?
Hahaha.
He did say, timer starts when you get in the car.
Wait!
Guys, you did say
It's the cards I didn't get.
Was it 250?
Fuck, I lost my train of thought.
Hahaha.
I forgot what I was going to say.
What was I trying to say?
I don't remember.
Brain is so tired.
Oh my god!
Okay, I remember.
Okay, so you guys said the last the last couple levels is like incredibly difficult because it's timed.
But like, but like, does that mean I can do the car strat?
Hahaha.
Does that mean the car strat will work?
If I just walk?
Hahaha.
Wait!
What do you mean?
It worked here.
The lumber king.
God.
Okay, if I destroy cars, I get money, right?
I just have to destroy other people's cars.
Wait, you're right.
To myself.
Like I said, you're right as I talk to myself.
Oh my god, Doki.
You're so right.
Okay.
Cat, thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Look, I was just telling myself that I'm right.
Alright, get over here.
I need your money.
I need money.
Money can be exchanged for goods and services.
Doki is so cool.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright.
You next.
Oh shit.
Wait, nevermind.
I need to fix my car.
Give me a sec.
I'll be back.
You think you're safe?
Alright, here you go.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, here you go.
Who's next?
You!
That's right.
Who's next?
Oh, you saw that?
Good for you.
You saw that?
That's right, you did.
Isn't it great?
People are lining up to get, like, to die.
Look, look at that.
There's this other car.
Wait your turn!
Wait your turn, sir!
Wait your- you know what?
Two for one special.
Alright.
Oh shit, I have to wait.
Give me a sec.
Stay there.
I gotta wait.
Just stay there.
Stay there!
Why didn't you listen?
I said stay there!
Get it.
It's okay.
I'm safe.
You housed a criminal.
Stop resisting.
Alright.
It's fine.
You're next.
This is the easiest way to earn money.
Alright.
There we go.
Alright, guys.
You!
Yeah!
Do you not see I'm doing something very important?
There we go.
We're good now.
This is my job.
Why do I look for money when the money can come to me?
Alright.
Cool, Lisa.
I'm so cool now.
Yippee!
I'm so cool!
Look how cool I am!
Yippee!
Guys, I can't afford Florida.
We gotta...
Guys, I wonder if anybody has ever pulled in money together to just buy a state.
Guys, if you think about it, if everyone, if all the dragoons pull in their money, we can legally buy a country.
We can make a Kickstarter and just legally buy a country.
Or Florida.
What's the cheapest state you can buy?
I don't think that's how it works.
Guys, we can have a Kickstarter!
Let's pull in all our money together!
Let's do it together!
Wyoming is the cheapest state.
Alright, hello.
We can buy a town!
Wait!
Okay, if we don't make enough money, we'll buy a town.
Okay, I'm cool-dokey now.
I'm so cool.
Let's go.
Oh yeah, I'm trying to get in.
Alright, follow Snake and find three strikes of evidence against him.
Don't miss any items.
Why do I have to drive?
Alright.
Yeah, we can just buy like a small town that has like a population of like 500 or something.
And we all pull our money together.
I can be mayor!
I mean, I feel like I'd be a really good mayor though.
Wait.
That's only strike two?
I've been doing that all day.
Ah, yes.
Your $50 can contribute to Doki Land or Doki Town.
As someone who lives here, oh wait.
I promise you don't want to buy this freaking magnet of a state.
Alright, I gotta go back to the casino.
Why the fuck is that time?
Alright.
What do I- okay, it's over here.
I was gonna say.
Oh my god.
Why can't I cheese this like I did before?
Just buy a microstate.
They're not legally recognized anyway.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, maybe one day we can make Doki Land a reality or Doki Town a reality.
Yay!
Yeah!
We did it!
Drive to Captain Mcglass.
I should be able to steal his car.
I completed his mission.
Alright, chief.
I need money.
I will not stop until I get Florida.
Plow King.
Alright, chief.
Oh, he's gone.
I can commit lots of crime now.
He's gone, guys.
Alright, there has to be a car.
Alright, here we go.
You.
No!
How did he juke me?
I said you!
It should work.
I said you.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Get over here.
Both of you.
I need money.
Get over here.
Start steaming!
Don't make me bring the bus!
I will bring the bus!
Wait a minute.
They're so tanky.
Wait, why are they so tanky?
Why are they so tanky?
What the fuck?
How are you guys so tanky?
You're supposed to explode!
Oh no.
I hit him one more time.
Okay, give me a sec.
Wait, he hit me!
He hit me!
Officer!
Wait!
That's not fair!
I didn't do anything!
I did nothing!
He hit me!
No!
Oh my god, I'm still okay.
I'm first frame!
I was framed!
Officer!
I did not commit no crime!
He framed me!
She did nothing wrong!
I give up.
I give up, guys.
I was doing different crimes!
This wasn't the crime I committed!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Guys!
No, I saw him!
Oh my god, I'm out, I'm out, I'm out!
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out!
Alright, I need something faster.
Okay, no!
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm sad.
I can't believe it.
I just...
Women just want one thing.
Oh yeah, you're right.
I should save.
You're right, guys.
Good idea.
I didn't save.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
I see, captain.
I'm here.
I'm here to be cool.
But also, maybe there's money here.
Yes, there is!
Nice.
Yippee!
Money!
Alright.
Money, money, money.
I like money.
Alright, nice.
Is there any money up top?
No, there isn't.
I guess I'll talk to the sea, captain.
Hello, hello, captain.
What?
What favor?
Not the fish!
Save the sea, captain's fish.
Collect all the fish.
Before the time runs out.
Okay, get in my vehicle.
Where is it?
Alright, Skinner, we're gonna save the fish, guys!
It's okay, they can survive a little longer.
They're mutated.
It's fine.
In fact, you might say they're sort of able to breathe a little bit outside of water.
Wait, where's the other fish?
Oh, it's a- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, give me a sec.
Wait, there's 22?!
Oh, fuck, I have to be a little faster.
I didn't realize there were 22 of them.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
We're almost there.
Just 5%.
Oh, no.
Get out of the road!
This is for cars only!
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, hey, it's Krusty Land.
It's Bar- What was it called?
Beer Land?
Wait, there's Krusty Studios?
I could be going to Krusty Studios right now?
Oh, my God, there's money there.
That's where all the celebrities are.
Celebrities have money?
Oh, yeah, it's Duff Land.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Like, it's one of the lands.
I was like, what was it called again?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I can't- I can't think right now.
I have to go get more fish.
Oh, no.
Why are they so far from each other?
Skidder, drive faster in your fucking sedan!
How are they so far?
Oh, guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
No!
I had to fucking you turn.
I had to- Okay, okay, I won't fuck around this time.
Guys, I won't fuck around this time.
I got this.
God, the time event is so brutal.
It's actually so brutal.
I have to go straight in.
Alright.
Oh!
It's okay.
I need to learn how to drift.
Alright.
Oh!
We're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it this time.
We have a lot more time.
Oh, no.
Please, please get away from me!
Move out of the way!
Okay, a minute.
Get out!
Get out of the way!
I have an important mission!
Alright.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Alright.
50 seconds.
I can do this in 50 seconds.
As long as I keep driving.
Just keep driving.
Just keep driving, Skinner.
It's alright.
Your mom likes it when you go fast.
It'll make your mom sad.
There's no way I missed one.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that, guys.
Don't say that.
The arrows didn't say I missed any.
No, no!
Not again!
No!
Now I'm stuck!
Okay, I'm figuring it out.
No, actually.
No, I accidentally missed that in my car!
Alright.
It's fine.
Okay.
I'm learning how to drift, guys.
I figured it out.
As long as I go straight, it should be fine.
Oh my god, get out.
Move out of the way!
Stop being on the road!
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay, I have not slowed down at all.
There's no way I can fuck this up this time.
Jesus Christ.
I'm even taking shortcuts.
No, it's a bored road.
Guys.
Cars have to right away.
This is a minute.
I got a whole minute.
Alright.
45 seconds.
Come on!
They're so fucking far away from each other!
Guys, I think I should not have brought a sedan for this mission.
No!
I just said the sedan might have been the problem.
I think bringing a family car might have been the issue.
No, no, no.
Oh my god, there it is.
There it is.
Yay!
I made it!
I made it, guys.
I don't know about you, but that looks like a car that made it.
Guys, please don't touch my car.
Guys, please.
Please don't touch my car.
I just...
Guys, guys, please.
Please don't touch my car.
Guys, please.
I have like...
Please, please.
Please don't touch my car.
I have 1 HP on my car.
Okay.
Alright, we just gotta be safe.
Now.
As long as no other car runs into me, everything will be okay.
I drive and follow...
I drive and follow traffic laws now.
Alright?
I'm on the left side.
Look at me go.
I'm following traffic rules.
Beep, beep.
Left turn.
Right turn.
If anybody hits me, it's...
If anybody hits me, it's their fault.
There we go.
Look at us go.
We're law-abiding citizens.
Look at that.
Everything is fine.
Let me just slowly go.
Alright, now we can do whatever the fuck we want.
Woo!
Alright, nice.
See, everything is fine now.
Yay!
Okay, that's a little awkward.
Alright, so I see the captain again.
Yay!
I made it!
See, look, I'm on the other side.
Alright.
We're almost at the sea, captain.
I did the thing, captain!
Hello!
Still counts, exactly.
Really?
Where did he go?
Huh?
What is it?
Destroy the black limo to find Bart?
No, I wanted to go to the...
I wanted to go to the fucking...
The Krusty Land.
Oh my god, wait, that's a cop.
Wait, okay, I should not have a sedan for this.
Oh my god!
Why do I keep using a sedan for these missions?
Oh, this is gonna take a while.
This is gonna take a while.
I got the wrong car.
How was I supposed to know I had to destroy a car?
I thought I was gonna do errands!
This is my errand car!
There we go.
Alright.
He's almost down.
There we go.
We're halfway.
You know what, the sedan ain't so bad.
Oh, my sedan's about to fucking explode.
Alright, give me a sec.
I gotta find a wrench.
Real quick.
Okay, I'll be back.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, we're fine.
We're okay now.
There we go.
Get down!
You know they're not!
We're in Springfield!
Who the fuck recycles in Springfield?
Yo, man.
Are you watching?
Oh my god, he's 1 HP.
He's 1 HP.
Please.
Please, no, not uphill!
Not uphill!
No!
No, my one weakness!
Crash, please!
Crash!
Oh, no!
I did it!
Alright.
Okay, I have a real car for this now.
Alright, get out.
They crashed.
They like crashed into me and still didn't register!
Alright, now I have a real car for this.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
I have a real car now.
It should do like triple the damage instead of a fucking sedan.
Okay, this should have done triple the damage looking at the stats.
It should have done triple damage but I guess not?
How did I do less damage than the fucking sedan?
I don't understand!
You can hit it.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is going worse.
I don't know how that's possible.
Okay, there we go.
I did more than I ever done before.
No.
No, please.
I saved so much money.
Please.
No, no, don't.
Don't, don't, don't hit them!
Don't push me into them!
Please!
I can't afford to go to jail again!
Please.
Please go over there.
Please!
Just hit something!
Oh my god!
I missed!
Guys, I don't think we're gonna hit him.
I hit him once and that was it.
Unless...
No, he turned.
He turned!
He fucking did!
Alright, this is okay.
I got this now.
And he hit zero damage?!
I crashed into you head on!
I'm stuck.
How?
I crashed into you!
I don't understand.
I don't understand!
I crashed into you!
How are you able to live?!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it.
The closest progress I ever made was to Sedan.
It's military grade limo.
What is this made out of?
Please!
Crash!
Yes!
I need you in the corner!
That's right!
Okay.
He's stuck.
This is it!
He can't get out!
I did it!
I locked it in!
I winched it!
This is it!
You can't get out now!
I did it!
That's...
How are you alive?!
That's right!
One more for the ride!
There we go.
It's just that easy.
This is where you die!
I'm a fucking genius, guys.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
That's all you have to do.
Just lock him in.
Alright.
I did it.
I killed Bart.
He was...
That was the plan, right?
Wait, what?
What's the point?
What?
Why didn't you tell me in the first place?
Wait, Bart the sea spanker?
Okay, before we do, I need to rob Krusty.
Alright.
Before we do all of that, I need to rob Krusty so I can afford my new outfit.
I'll be right back.
Oh.
Task complete?
Alright.
I'll be right back.
Krusty's over there.
God damn it!
Not the time!
It's always the time.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'm heading over.
I'll head over.
Wait.
Wait, no.
I have to go that way.
Oh my god.
I fucked up.
I...
Whoops.
Alright.
Now I'm heading over for real.
Wait, how do I get over there?
How do I...
How do I get over there?
Hello?
How do I... Oh, I have to jump over?
I was so confused.
I was like, how?
Alright, it's this way.
Okay, I got this.
Alright.
I'm jumping over.
I'm gonna do something that no one has done before.
Let me try that again.
Let me...
I just didn't have enough speed.
Okay.
Nailed it.
Alright.
Watch this.
Now I have the speed.
I should have the speed now.
Woo!
There we go.
Alright.
Am I in?
Okay.
Okay, but like, it did look cool though.
Did it not?
Guys, did it not look cool?
It looked so cool.
But it looked so cool.
I have to do this again?
No!
If I do it...
I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Guys, if I had known that...
I fucked it up, which means I restarted the entire thing, I might not have done what I've done.
I might not have done what I did today.
If I knew.
If I...
Alright, yes.
Alright, if I knew my actions had consequences, I wouldn't fuck around and found out.
I'm so sad.
It was so smart to what I did to that stupid nipple.
Oh my god.
I don't know if I can do it again.
It was like a one in a lifetime opportunity.
No, I can't!
I can't lock him in like I did.
Please.
Actions have consequences.
Since when?
When was that last thing?
Shit.
What do you mean?
Crash into me.
That's right.
Keep crashing.
I don't care.
This is crap.
The slow game.
Like, what is this?
You showed up.
She's lost.
Guys, maybe this is not the right car.
I'll get another car.
Mr. Plow, it's time to bring it.
No, I keep getting hit!
Don't get in!
It's time to bring in Mr. Plow.
I'm ready to call in the big boys.
Alright.
Where's Mr. Plow?
Mr. Plow.
It's time.
I brought the Plow King instead.
Same thing.
Same business.
That limo bet.
I'm gonna plow him down.
Are you ready for a plowing?
Boom!
Okay, I missed.
Okay.
That's okay.
That's okay, slow.
There we go.
God damn it, he drove out of it.
I'm gonna give him the limo back shots that he was never prepared for.
Oh my god, no, the cops want me too.
Please, I just... Please, I've been through a lot.
I should get like...
I should get like a little plus one forgiveness.
Alright, he should be driving this way, right?
I just...
It was a 50-50.
It was a 50-50, guys.
I lost a 50-50.
How was I supposed to know?
How was I...
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I'm so...
Well...
Okay, this is it.
I have missed the plow king.
And I still do zero damage on the plow.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
It's not fine anymore.
He got out.
He got out of it.
Oh my god.
I have to do a U-turn.
It's not fine.
I gotta do U-turns.
I actually have to like sit... I'm sitting up closer to the monitor right now.
I'm not lounging anymore.
Oh my god.
Why are there so many people here in the board road?
God!
Okay, I'm leaning in.
You know like those locked in?
When you're locked in and you lean in?
That's me right now.
Okay, I'm taking you over there.
I'm taking you over there.
You are not leaving.
You are... Oh, you were not supposed to get out.
Please!
I wish I...
If I do me fucking around because I have to restart this I wouldn't have fucked around to do this stupid level mission after the most insane gamer tech I've ever done.
Please explode!
EXPLODE!
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Okay, before I talk to the sea captain, let's figure out how to get on the boat.
Let's figure it out.
He nailed it.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, you're right.
I should save.
I'll make it across.
Weeeee.
I'm so sad.
How was that private property?
It was public property meant to be destroyed.
Okay.
It's okay.
I have time to not talk to him.
I have time to not talk.
No, no, no.
He missed.
That's fucking right, idiot.
Can't catch me.
Alright, nice.
Okay, let's figure this out.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
We have analysis right now.
How do we get up the ship?
I can't do this.
I can't be safe.
Oh shit, nice.
Oh my god.
I can't save.
Wait.
How did I do that?
I can't save.
The ram was correct.
Alright, we're gonna figure this out to get there.
Before we do anything, we gotta figure out how to get out of there.
Evan died laughing in a minute.
I almost passed out.
Jackson, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, we're not using that car.
We're not.
That car might not be it.
That car looks pretty rough.
Okay, let's get the sedan.
The perfect car.
Alright.
Let's test run this.
We gotta test run this.
Alright.
We can do this with a sedan.
I believe.
Please.
No!
The car was too good!
It was too good of a car!
Go back.
Wait, I can do this on the lighthouse?
Alright, how do we do this on the lighthouse?
The car was actually too good.
Alright.
Wait, we can do this with the lighthouse?
Kowalski analysis now.
Wait, I can do this.
I can make the jump.
I can do this.
Oh my god!
We did it!
Alright.
We did it.
Alright, we figured it out.
Alright, nice.
How do I get out?
Oh wait, hey.
I need this.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
I think I can afford Florida.
I think it was $200, right?
Was it $200?
It doesn't matter, I have $250.
Wait, the secret car is up there?
How do I get the secret car?
It's up here?
How do I get it?
Oh my god.
I don't know how.
Where's the secret car?
Oh, it's in the shipping container?
Okay.
Okay, it's in one of these containers.
Okay, don't worry, I'm exploring now.
I made it.
Wait, what secret car is it?
Oh, it's in this one?
Oh, I can't get up there.
Okay.
Green one?
Oh, this one!
Okay, I can jump these boxes.
Alright, parkour!
Parkour!
Don't worry.
I can parkour.
Yay!
Wait, what's this?
What reference is this one?
Oh shit, look at my cool ass car though.
I have no idea what car this is.
I don't know what reference this is.
The boat car?
I don't remember what episode this is from.
Oh shit, hot pants!
I know that.
The boat mobile.
Alright guys, I figured it out.
Okay.
Do I keep it?
I must have kept it, right?
Alright, I need to get this though.
Boop!
Get over here.
I need that money.
Oh my god, I did it.
I'm in.
And I got my hot pants too.
I got my hot pants and I got my boat mobile.
Alright.
I accidentally reset my car, but that's okay.
Alright, now that I got all I need, it's time to do something very important.
It's time to buy Florida.
Florida.
This was the entire purpose of this game.
Alright.
Where's the closest clothing store?
Guys.
I gotta go back up.
That's fine.
I can't save, guys.
It won't let me save.
It won't let me save when I'm in the middle of a mission.
Stupid Flanders.
This is all- I know this is all Flanders' fault.
It's alright, I have my boat mobile.
Alright, I have enough money now.
Guys, all I'm saying is that I haven't got arrested by the cops in like a long- in like at least an hour.
So like, I'm doing something right.
Alright.
Woooo!
Oh my god, okay.
It's okay, I'm next to the comic book store.
I can't get arrested.
Alright.
I am ready to own Flo-
Where's the- I have to complete the mission to be able to buy clothes?
I-
Are you fucking- Okay, I guess I'm not ready to own Florida.
Yes!
How was I supposed to know that?
Alright, back to- back to the captain.
Back- I wanted to fucking- Oh my god, I thought I could drive through that.
I didn't know you could buy clothes in the middle of a mission!
What if I want to look different?
I could change cars in the middle of a mission!
Why can't I buy clothes?
Oh no, I'm not gonna make it, it's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's not fine.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
It's okay, I can do it after this mission.
It'll be fine.
I'll just- I'll just buy it after the mission.
And then it'll be fine.
I- I'm patient enough.
I'm patient.
Hello.
Alright.
It's fine, my car is okay.
I just need to go to the lighthouse and then do the jump.
It's fine, I have plenty of time.
Alright.
It's fine, we have the strat.
Right here.
I'm gonna make it!
Nice.
I made it.
Alright, Bart, I'm here now.
Where's Bart?
Where is he?
Hello?
Bart, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Hey, Bart!
Huh?
You okay?
Kiss my grit?
Yay, I did it!
I found Bart!
Huh?
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean level 3 is so big?
Huh?
Why am I Marge?
Why am I- Why am I Marge?
But...
I just won one thing.
There's no way.
Oh my god, I'm going back.
You can't take this away from me.
You can't- You can't take this away from me!
I did it!
I refuse!
I'm coming back!
I refuse to leave!
You can't take this from me!
I got my car.
Do you know how much I sacrificed?
I'm coming over.
I saved all my earnings for this.
I almost had enough and then they made me buy a bus.
And then I almost had enough again and then they made me buy cool clothes.
You can't take this away.
I earned this.
My entire life savings was spent on this.
Alright.
It's fine.
I can run over two more people before the cops will notice.
Alright.
This is my reward.
There you go.
See?
One.
I told you I can run over two more people before they notice.
This is it.
This is my reward.
This is my fucking reward.
I don't care.
This is it.
Oh my god.
I'm beautiful.
Let's go.
You know how much I sacrificed to be Florida.
Finally, I'm beautiful.
I'm so beautiful, yes.
Yes.
Stop the car.
I wanna be beautiful on top.
I wanna be beautiful on top of the car.
It's a parade.
Guys, clap.
Wave your hands.
I'm on a parade right now.
Oh wait, my car's in the middle of the street.
Oh no.
My car's in the middle of the street.
Alright, let me move the car real quick, guys.
Let me move the car.
The parade stopped for a little bit.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're not.
Get away.
No!
My parade!
It's okay.
It's alright.
I have another car.
Wave your hands.
Wave your hands, everybody.
It's a doki parade.
And here to represent Florida is me, the most beautiful person in this parade.
Wave your hands, everybody.
Wave your hands.
Wave to the...
Blow them kisses.
I'll blow...
No!
Get back here!
My float!
My float.
It's okay.
It's okay, I'll get another one.
I shall kidnap another car.
It's okay.
I will still be beautiful.
Hey, Choa.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Behold, Florida.
Nick, like the grandchild of Gamlord.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Duck, thank you for the superchat.
Mistoki bird, what is your first act as governor of Florida?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
My first decree as governor of Florida is that is that there's no more bedtime.
No more bedtime.
If I see you sleep in Florida, it's over.
You get deported.
You get...
You get deported to Wisconsin.
No more sleep.
That's my queen.
The national end of bedtime.
No more
bedtime.
Wisconsin?
I don't know.
This feels like a good state to feel like a good place to deport to.
Please, Dookie, I haven't slept in 10 days.
I need to sleep.
Not in Florida!
Don't make me send you to Detroit!
I could send you to Detroit instead!
Alright.
Yeah.
Not Detroit.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
We are not finishing this game today.
I'm fucking tired.
I'm tired.
My mission was to get Florida and I got Florida.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Have you slept for me?
Head to bed, cause you deserve it.
Let me save my game real quick.
That was a fun game!
I can't believe it gets harder.
I can't believe this game is gonna get even harder.
But we'll see.
We'll try.
Maybe we'll finish it next time.
We'll finish it in the second week.
And I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!